TO THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FOR TUESDAY APRIL
THIRD I USUALLY DO NOT LIKE TO
START THE COMMITTEE WITHOUT.
A MEMBER OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HERE WITH US BUT THEY HAVE NOT
YET JOINED US COME TOLD THEY'RE
ON THEIR WAY BUT WE'RE GONNA GET
STARTED AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
AND THE FIRST BILL WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY TO SEVENTY FOUR MISTER
QUIRK.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK COMMITTEE.
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THESE THOUGHTFUL AMENDMENTS.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY FOUR
CHANGES HOW COURTS RESOLVE PET
OWNERSHIP CASES.
ARE SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
EMPOWERS JUDGES TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE CARE FOR PETS.
DETERMINING SOUL OR JOINT OFF
AUTHORSHIP.
CALIFORNIA'S A COMMUNITY
PROPERTY STATE ALL COMMUNITY
PROPERTY.
AND DEBT ACQUIRED FROM THE DATE
OF A MARRIAGE AND TOLD THE.
MARSHALL CUT OFF DATE.
IS.
DIVIDED AND DISTRIBUTED EQUALLY.
DIVISIONS PROPERTY INCLUDES PETS
LIKE MANY PET OWNERS AYE VIEW MY
PET AS MEMBER OF THE FAMILY.
WELL THIS.
DOES NOT CHANGE YOUR PETS LEGAL
CHARACTERISED CHARACTERIZATION
AS PROPERTY IT DOES GIVE
GUIDANCE TO THE COURT.
COURTS ARE MAKING PET OWNERSHIP
DETERMINATIONS YEAH OUTCOMES ARE
VERY DIFFERENT FROM COURT TO
COURT.
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF GUIDANCE IN
CALIFORNIA LAW.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY FOUR TO
REMEDY THIS.
WITH WITH ME TODAY IS BRANDY
CONSUL.
OUT WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA
AND I SEE WE ALSO HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL HERE. THANK YOU.
AND I WENT UP.
THANK YOU WELL WE'RE GONNA PAUSE
IN.
ESTABLISH A COURT IF YOU CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HERE
CUNNINGHAM CHAO.
CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN HERE RATES.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
THEY YOU THERE IS A MOTION IS
THEIR SECOND.
AND A SECOND AND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M BRANDY CANCEL
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA AMERICA'S FOURTH.
OLDEST HUMANE SOCIETY.
DIVORCE IS ONE A MOST COMMON
REASONS THAT PEOPLE OF SURRENDER
THEIR PETS TO SHELTERS LIKE THE
ONE THAT THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA
OPERATES.
CURRENTLY JUDGES IN DIVORCE
CASES TREAT PETS LIKE COMPUTERS
ARE COUCHES THAT IS THERE JUST
PIECES OF PROPERTY TO AK AWARD
TO ONE SIDE OR THE OTHER BASS
ANA HOPEFULLY EQUITABLE DIVISION
OF PROPERTY. THIS APPROACH IS
JUST A POOR FIT FOR DISPUTE
INVOLVING BELOVED PETS
THE BOND BETWEEN PETS AND HUMANS
IS OFTEN LOST IN NEGOTIATIONS
OUR PETS BECOME PAWNS AND
PROTRACTED NEGOTIATIONS OF IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH UNBALANCED.
POWER SITUATIONS THIS OFTEN
MEANS EXPENSIVE AND PROLONG
DISPUTES ABOUT PETS IN OUR
FUTURE. ANIMALS ARE AS MR QUIRK
SAID A LEGAL MATTER PERSONAL
PROPERTY IN CALIFORNIA AB TWENTY
TO SEVENTY FOUR DOESN'T CHANGE
THIS AT ALL. THE IDEA BEHIND
THIS MEASURE IS THAT SIMPLY THAT
ANIMALS ARE A SPECIAL TYPE OF
PROPERTY WORTHY OF SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION UNDER THE LAW.
NONE OF US CAN SPEWED THE
OBVIOUS DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A DOG
AND COUCH.
OR THE UNIQUE FACTORS THAT GO
INTO A DECIDING WHERE PET GOES
IN DIVORCE IT'S AS CLEAR
DISTINGUISH THIS THIS THIS
DISTINGUISHING FEATURE BETWEEN
PROPERTY TYPES THAT IS CURRENTLY
UNRECOGNIZED IN DIVORCE LAW.
THAT AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY FOUR
SEEKS TO REMEDY.
AB TWO TWENTY FOUR IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE LONG STANDING STATE
NATIONAL POLICY OF TREATING
ANIMALS UNIQUE AS UNIQUE PIECES
OF PROPERTY CALIFORNIA HAS OVER
ONE HUNDRED LAWS THAT TREAT
ANIMALS DIFFERENT AND COUCHES.
INCLUDING ANTI CRUELTY HUNTING
REGULATIONS AND MANY MORE
CALIFORNIANS RECOGNIZE THAT EVEN
THOUGH THEY REMAIN PROPERTY
ANIMALS MERITS SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION UNDER THE LAW.
AB TWENTY TWO A SEVENTY FOUR IS
A CLOSE COUSIN TO FAMILY CODE
SIXTY THREE TWENTY. WHICH WAS
ENACTED JUST FOUR YEARS AGO.
IT EXPRESSLY ALLOWS JUDGES TO
INCLUDE PETS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROTECTIVE ORDERS AND
GET EXCLUSIVE CARE POSSESSION
AND CONTROL TO ONE PERSON IN A
RELATIONSHIP BEFORE THE COURT.
THE LAW FIRM THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN PEOPLE AND PETS IN THIS
INSTANCE AND AB TWENTY TO
SEVENTY FOUR REPRESENTS A VERY
SIMILAR AFFIRMATION.
WHEN CLOSE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS BECOME COME BEFORE
THE COURTS AND PETS ARE INVOLVED
WE SIMPLY WANT OUR JUDGES TO
HAVE DISCRETION TO PAY SPECIAL
HEED TO THE ANIMALS.
PAKISTANI DISPUTES ARE ON THE
RISE NOBODY TO MAKEYOUR
DISPUTES THAT AND THEY'RE COSTLY
TO COUPLES AND THE COURTS.
WE'VE CITED A TWENTY FOURTEEN
SURVEY CONDUCTED BY THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF MATRIMONIAL LAWYERS
IN WHICH MORE THAN A QUARTER OF
FAMILY LAW ATTORNEYS CITED AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF CASES.
BY CLARIFYING AND STREAMLINING
THIS PROCESS FOR THE COURT'S AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FOUR WILL
HAVE A VALUABLE BENEFIT OF
REDUCING PET RELATED DISPUTES.
AND CONSERVING THE RESOURCES OF
OUR ALREADY OVERTAXED COURT
SYSTEM I URGE YOUR YES VOTE ON
ABC TWENTY TO SEVENTY FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT IT'S
WITH.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER FEARING
NOT HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THANK YOU CAN
FACT HERE. ON BEHALF OF.
THE CDA GO HUMANE SOCIETY BEST
FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY AND ALSO
THE A SPC EXPRESSING STRONG
SUPPORT IN URGING DRIVE VOTE
THANK YOU. THINK MY MISTAKE.
THAT ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME OWNERSHIP.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE BROWN I'M A
CERTIFIED FAMILY LAW SPECIALIST
WHO'S BEEN PRACTICING LAW FOR
OVER TWENTY FOUR YEARS.
I AM THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE ASSOCIATION OF CERTIFIED
FAMILY LAW SPECIALIST WERE
COMPRISED OF OVER SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE. CERTIFIED FAMILY
LAW SPECIALIST ACROSS THE STATE
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL NOT
BECAUSE WE DON'T ALL LOVE
ANIMALS I HAVE TWO CATS WHO I
CONSIDER MY CHILDREN AS WELL.
HOWEVER UNDER CURRENT LAW
ANIMALS OUR COMMUNITY PROPERTY
THEY ARE AN ASSET TO BE AWARDED
TO EITHER A HUSBAND OR A WIFE.
RIGHT NOW AS THE WITNESS IN
SUPPORT STATED UNDER FAMILY CODE
SECTION SIXTY THREE TWENTY BE IF
THERE IS ABUSE.
THEN THE COURT DEFINITELY HAS
JURISDICTION TO AWARD AN ANIMAL
TO ONE PARTY AND IT'S USUALLY
THE VICTIM TO ENSURE THAT THAT
ANIMAL IS SAFE AND FREE FROM ANY
HARM. BECAUSE IN THOSE
SITUATIONS AN ANIMAL CAN BE USED
AS A PAWN THE COURT ALREADY HAS
THAT DISCRETION ONE OF OUR MAIN
CONCERNS HERE IS THE COURTS ARE
ALREADY BACKLOG I WAS IN COURT
JUST THIS WEEK ON A CUSTODY
SITUATION WITH TWO SMALL
CHILDREN.
I CAN'T GET INTO COURT UNTIL THE
END OF NOVEMBER.
NOW WERE GOING TO BE ADDING
CASSIE DISPUTES OVER CHILDREN I
UNDERSTAND THE.
.
THE STATISTICS THAT WERE RAISED
BY THE WITNESS IN SUPPORT BUTTON
TWENTY FOUR YEARS I'VE ONLY HAD
ONE CASE WHERE THERE IS A REAL
DISPUTE OVER A DOG JUST ONE IN
TWENTY FOUR YEARS. NOW WE GOING
TO BE HAVING JUDGES HAVING TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION AS TO.
JOINT OWNERSHIP CUSTODY
VISITATION RIGHTS PEOPLE ARGUING
OVER ANIMALS AND TAKING THE
CHILDREN.
AND THE LANE FROM NOW WHAT WERE
FROM NOVEMBER MAYBE TELL NEXT
YEAR SO THAT I CAN GET A HEARING
ON CHILDREN FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOU KNOW VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ISRAEL.
SO WHAT IS THE PROCEDURE NOW IF
THERE IS A DISPUTE REGARDING A A
PET
A FAMILY PET. IT IN A DIVORCE O.
DISSOLUTION PROCEEDINGS.
IF YOU ARE IF EITHER PARTY IS
BRINGS WOULD BRING A MOTION TO
REQUESTED THE COURT WOULD HAVE
THE JURISDICTION TO ISSUE AN
INTERIM ORDER JUST AS IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN.
THE JURISDICTION TO ISSUE AN
INTERIM ORDER ON ANY OTHER PIECE
OF PERSONAL PROPERTY WHAT
USUALLY HAPPENS IN ALL HONESTY
IS IF ONE PERSON WHO IS MORE
ASSOCIATED ARE ALIGNED WITH THE
PAT. EITHER REMAINS IN THE
FAMILY RESIDENCE OR LEAVES THAT
PERSON USUALLY TAKES THE PAT
WITH HIM. AND AGAIN IN ALL
HONESTY NINE TIMES OUT OF TEN
WHOEVER HAS CUSTODY OF THE
CHILDREN ARE PRIMARY CUSTODY
USUALLY HAS THE PACKED WITH THEM
BECAUSE THAT'S USUALLY ALIGNED
WITH THE CHILD. AND I WOULD JUST
ADD THAT. THIS BILL WOULDN'T
CHANGE
THAT BUT WHEN THERE IS A
DISPUTE.
IT GIVES THE CRITERIA CARRIED
THE ANIMAL. AND THE PROBLEM WE
HAVE IS THAT FROM COURT TO COURT
THINGS VERY AND THIS GIVES THE
JUDGE'S CRITERIA UNDER WHICH TO.
MANAGE THAT SITUATION
AND IF I MAY ADD AS WELL THAT
THE IT THE SITUATION HERE IS
THAT THE COURTS AREN'T SURE HOW
TO DEAL WITH THIS AREA OF THE
LAW RIGHT WE ALL KNOW THAT PETS
ARE PERSONAL PROPERTY. BUT
THERE'S SO MUCH IN THE MEDIA
THERE SO MANY ARGUMENTS BE MADE
BEFORE THE COURT BUT IT IT
MUDDIES THE ISSUE. AND SO WE
CONSIDER THIS ACTUALLY A RELIEF
VALVE FOR THE BACKLOG OF CASES
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES CLEAR
DIRECTIVE TO THE COURTS ON HOW
TO HANDLE THESE CASES.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT JUDGES ARE
IN COMPLETE CONTROL OF THEIR
COURTROOMS RIGHT SO THIS JUST IS
WE WOULD THINK THAT THEY WOULD
EMBRACE THIS PROCESS BECAUSE IT
SIMPLIFIES AS IT PROVIDES A.
VERY CLEAR DIRECTIVE AND.
.
IT AND EXPEDITES IT IN A VERY
EFFICIENT WAY.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
COMMENTS WERE MADE ABOUT THE
BACKLOG AND HOW THIS MIGHT
INCREASE THE BACKLOG I WILL BE
VOTING FOR THIS BUT I I WOULD
REQUEST THAT THAT THAT THAT
DISCUSSION CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THERE ISN'T THAT THAT
WE'RE NOT.
INCREASING THE BACKLOG FOR THE
CHILDREN TO TAKE CARE VICIOUS
REGARDING THE PETS THAT WOULD BE
MY ONLY CONCERN BUT I WILL BE
VOTING FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU I'M GONNA HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SO AS I UNDERSTAND THE AMENDED
VERSION THE BILL SETS FORTH THE
STANDARD THAT TAKES.
SO SO JUDGE WOULD TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION.
THE CARE OF THE PET AND DEFINES
CARES CERTAINLY.
SO HOW IS THE JUDGE GOING TO
DETERMINE. THAT.
YOU AND UNDER.
THE CONTEMPLATION OF THIS NEW
PROCEDURE.
WELL I THINK THAT THAT OUT OF
GOPHERS BUT WE WOULD EXPECT THAT
THE JUDGES WOULD MAKE THESE
CONSIDERATIONS BASED ON THE
FACTS AND CIRCUMSTANCES BEFORE
THEM IN A CASE JUST LIKE THEY
WOULD ANY OTHER DECISION AND
DIVIDING EQUITABLE COMMUNITY
PROPERTY AND THE NOTION OF A PET
CARE. CLINICAL CARE WE THINK IS
STRAIGHTFORWARD ENOUGH THAT A
TASK OF FOR A JUDGE WHO IS WELL
VERSED IN TO THESE TYPES OF
DECISIONS WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE.
AGAIN ON THE FACTS BEFORE THEM
SO. YOU KNOW THE FACTS WILL NEED
TO BE WEIGHED CERTAINLY BUT THAT
IS ALREADY BEING DONE THESE
CASES ARE ARGUE THESE ISSUES ARE
TO BE HEARD. AND IF I MAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
EXACTLY WHAT THE WITNESS STATED
IS OUR CONCERN.
UNDER FAMILY CODE SECTION TWO
SEVENTEEN ANY PERSON IS ENTITLED
TO AN EVIDENTIARY HEARING. SO IF
FAT MY SPOUSE AND I HAVE A
DISPUTE OVER THE CAT I AM THEN
ENTITLED TO AN EVIDENTIARY
HEARING WHY MIGHT WANT TO BRING
IN WITNESSES THE VETERINARIAN. A
TO TESTIFIED THAT I CAN PROVIDE
BETTER CARE FOR THE CAP WHICH
WILL INCREASE THE BACKLOG THAT'S
ONE OF OUR MAIN CONCERNS.
GOOD DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT
THOUGH THAT LOOK AT WORK OUT
WE'RE WORKING WITH ADDITIONAL
COUNSEL NOW. AND THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE INDICATED TO US THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH US ON
THE BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN.
AND SHOULD THEY DECIDE THAT
HAPPENED THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM
THEN I WOULD CERTAINLY
RECONSIDER IT BUT WE'RE WORKING
WITH JUDICIAL COUNCIL I THINK
THEY'RE IN THE BEST POSITION TO
MAKE THAT JUDGMENT AND I WILL BE
FOLLOWING. WITH THEM ON THAT.
OKAY I MEAN BUT IT'S STILL IT
OCCURS TO ME THAT IF YOU'RE
GONNA SET FORTH A NEW STANDARD.
AND.
ALLOW AN EVIDENTIARY HEARING
POTENTIALLY ARE EITHER PARTY TO
REQUEST ONE TO SAY HEY I CAN
TAKE CARE FIND A BETTER THAN
THAN. HERE SHE CAN TAKE CARE OF
FIDO.
THEN HOW ARE YOU NOT INCREASING
THE BACKLOG IF YOU HAVE MORE
GLARING THAN ANOTHER ISSUE HERE
CAN BE REQUESTED IN ANY CASE
UNDER CURRENT LAW EVEN WITHOUT
THIS.
YEAH BUT NOT NOW SETTING FORTH A
NEW STANDARD THAT'S GOTTA BE
THAT'S GOTTA BE LITIGATED SO I I
GUESS I.
TO.
MS RAISE THIS QUESTION I'VE GOT
THE SAME CONCERN LIKE YOU'VE GOT
A BACKLOG ALREADY OF CASES
INVOLVING CUSTODY WITH CHILDREN.
RIGHT I MEAN I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY CAN DISPUTE THAT THAT'S
OF EVIDENTIARY FACT IN THE WORLD
ANOTHER.
I MEAN MY WIFE PRACTICES FAMILY
LAW SHE'S HAVING THE SAME
ISSUES.
TRYING TO GET HEARINGS FOR FOR
CUSTODY CASES.
AND DISPUTES.
INVOLVING YOUNG KIDS AND IN THIS
TAKE TREMENDOUS ABOUT TIME GOT A
CALL EXPERTS GOT IT
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND.
NOW YOU'RE ADDING A NEW.
POTENTIAL SET HOWEVER I DON'T
KNOW HOW BIG THE SET IS BUT
YOU'RE ADDING A NEW POTENTIAL
SAT DISPUTES.
INVOLVING ANIMALS
SO HOW ARE YOU NOT CAN INCREASE
THE BACKLOG.
THE UP AGAIN AS THE CHAIR SAID
YOU CAN STILL ASK FOR THAT
WITHOUT THIS WHAT THIS DOES IS
SET A STANDARD.
AND DUBBED WE ARE WORKING WITH
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THEY ARE
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT BACKLOGS
THAN ANYONE ELSE'S.
AND I THINK THERE WOULD BE A
AND I'VE E. IT EXACTLY I THINK
THAT JUST BECAUSE YOU GET TO THE
OTHER QUESTION. IS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER I'M I'M ALSO I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT. BACKLOG ANYBODY
WHO HAS BEEN IN FAMILY COURT. OF
LAST YEAR'S CAN TELL YOU
ESPECIALLY IF YOU GO THROUGH A
PUBLIC.
PROCESS.
HOW LONG YOU WAIT FOR THESE
DETERMINATIONS TO BE MADE AND
I'M HOW UPSETTING? I HAD
INTERMEDIATE SITUATION AS ON
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN. AND I'M
ALSO CONCERNED THAT THIS IS KIND
OF OPENING UP THIS ENTIRE NEW
POINT OF LEVERAGE.
IN IN OTHER IN.
DIVORCE DISPUTE AND.
AND IN DIVORCES DISPUTES
ESPECIALLY WHEN OUR CHILDREN
INVOLVED.
SOMETIMES PROVIDING ANOTHER
POINT OF LEVERAGE.
FOR THE I HAVE.
FOR.
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO MAYBE HAS
MORE RESOURCES TO TO GO THROUGH
I I AM JUST IMAGINING THAT THERE
WILL BE.
PET PSYCHOLOGIST PRIDE AND THAT
THERE WERE I MEAN THAT THIS IS
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN RIGHT
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE.
CUSTODY ARRANGEMENTS MADE AND
THEN SOMEBODY'S GONNA WANT TO
MOVE AWAY ORDER I MEAN I CAN
IMAGINE AND I'M SORRY BECAUSE
I'VE SEEN KIND OF THE CHANGE IN
HOW PEOPLE DEAL WITH. THEIR PETS
AND THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
A COURT SYSTEM THAT SET UP RIGHT
NOW TO DEAL WITH OUR CHILDREN.
MAKES ME REALLY A.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SPELL I'M
NOT GONNA VOTE ON IT TODAY.
I'VE I'M NOT GONNA VOTE AGAINST
LAYOFF I I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING HOPEFULLY AM FROM
JUDICIAL COUNCIL BUT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING I CAN SUPPORT TODAY.
I'M HAVING HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
BEING IN FUELING COURT OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS IN AND SEEN HOW
LONG AND TO SEE QUITE FRANKLY
OW HOW CAN BE USED FAMILY COURT
AS. JUST LEVERAGE ON OTHER
ISSUES BECAUSE ANYBODY WHO'S
DEALT WITH DIVORCES NOW. HOW
PAINFUL THAT CAN BE AND AND HOW
MUCH LEVERAGES OFF AND UTILIZED?
IN ANY FORM AVAILABLE TO A
PERSON WHO HAS MOST MOUNT MONEY
SO. I'M I'M GONNA LAY OFF OF IT
TODAY I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO I WANT TO BE THERE
I JUST I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THIS WITHOUT
GETTING. A FULL UNDERSTAND FROM
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF.
WHAT THIS WOULD LOOK LIKE AND
HOW THIS WOULD AFFECT THE COURT?
LET.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU MISTER SO.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT THOUGH THE.
IN ADDITION TO CLARIFYING A
STANDARD OR SETTING STANDARDS.
YOU YOU WOULD ALSO ENABLE A
JUDGE TO TO DO SOME SORT OF
JOINT CUSTODY. YEAH RANGE OF THE
PAT.
I MEAN THAT.
TO ME THAT FURTHER COMPOUNDS THE
CONCERNS OVER BACKLOG BECAUSE
NOW YOU'VE GOT A CUSTODY ORDER
AND SOMEBODY NEEDS TO DROP OFF I
DON'T FIVE O'CLOCK ON FRIDAY.
AND THEY DON'T SHOW UP. AND THEN
YOU GOT PEOPLE RUNNING IN THE
COURT TO TRY TO GET IN. THAT
ORDER ENFORCED AND IT SEEMS LIKE
THAT THERE WOULD BE A
PROLIFERATION.
OF LITIGATION LIKE YOU SEE IN
CUSTODY DISPUTES OVER CHILDREN.
OVER PETS IS THAT A CONCERN
THAT.
YOU GUYS ARE ARE CONSIDERING.
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND AM MISTER CHAIR
MISTER CUNNINGHAM AND IN FACT
AND JENNIFER FEARING AGAIN I WE
JUST SPOKE WITH JUDICIAL
COUNCIL.
IN THAT IN THE AUDIENCE BEFORE
THAT'S AND LEARN ABOUT A DEATH
THAT THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AND HAVE
COMMITTED TO WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH THEM TO AVOID. MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT ONCE
THE COURT ORDERS UNDER THAT'S
WHICH AGAIN THEY ALREADY HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO WERE JUST
TRYING TO RUN TRYING TO PROMOTE
OR ACCELERATE. THESE TYPES OF
DISPUTES RETURN TO CREATE A
PATHWAY I'M A STANDARD TO MAKE
IT GO BETTER AND FASTER SO WE WE
DO FEEL ABOUT WORK WHICH INITIAL
COUNCIL WE CAN GET THE THOUGHT
OF A PLACE THAT IT RESOLVES. THE
CONCERN YOU'RE HAVING NOT
EXACERBATES IT A BUT AND WE
CERTAINLY CAN HANDLE.
WORKING WITH JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ON THIS JOINT CUSTODY
ARRANGEMENT UNDERSTAND THAT ONCE
THE JUDGE ORDERS THAT'S THE END
OF THE. UC FAMILY COURTS AND
DEALING WITH THIS MATTER IN ANY.
ONE LAST COMMENT ON THAT.
IF YOU LOOK IN SUB SECOND YOU
MIGHT WANT TO OWN A MICROPHONE
THERE THINK KIM. IF YOU LOOK IN
SUBSECTION A OF THE BILL IT DOES
TALK ABOUT PRIOR TO THE FINAL
DETERMINATION OF OWNERSHIP OF
THE PET ANIMAL. AND THEN YOU
HAVEYOUR JUDGMENT DETERMINATION
SO IN THIS INSTANCE YOU COULD
HAVE SOMEONE FILING A REQUEST
FOR ORDER. ASKING FOR AN
EVIDENTIARY HEARING ON DEPEND
ENTIRELY DAY ORDER FOR SOLAR
JOINT OWNERSHIP OF THE PAT AND
THEN ALSO DEALING WITH IT AGAIN
AT THE TIME OF THE FINAL TRIAL.
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT SEEING NONE ESCORT YOU
MAKE CLOTHES YEAH LET ME SAY
THAT I WILL NOT ALLOW THE BILL
TO GO FORWARD IF IT RESULTS IN A
SUBSTANTIAL.
.
YEAH A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN
THE CURRENT BACKLOG PERIOD.
I WORK WITH JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
PREVENT THAT.
I LET ME JUST SAY NOW THAT.
.
WELL AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY FOUR
MAKES IT CHANGES.
IT'S NOT A HUGE WIND AND IT
DOESN'T OPEN DIVORCE PROCEEDINGS
TO ANYTHING THAT HAS NOT BEEN
PART OF IT SUCH CASES
PREVIOUSLY.
OUR JUDGES ARE IN COMPLETE
CONTROL OF THEIR COURTROOM AND
WE ARE NOT COMPARING THIS WITH
THE CHILD. CUSTODY BATTLE WITH
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD.
ARE CONSIDERED WITH EXTENDED
TESTIMONY. I. AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY FOUR NAY THEIR SETS UP
ANY KIND OF PROCESS LIKE THAT.
NOR PROMOTES IT RATHER IT PUTS
THE DECISION MAKING AUTHORITY IN
THE HANDS OF THE JUDGE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY.
PROVIDES GUIDANCE SO THINGS WILL
NOT VERY FROM COURT TO COURT AND
AGAIN I PLEDGE NOT IN ANY WAY TO
INCREASE.
THE BACK BACK LIKE SHOULD IN
ANY SUBSTANTIAL WAY.
THANK YOU.
SO THERE IS A MOTION TO SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
NO CHOW. CHOW I CHU CHU AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
THE TEXAS TO WELL FIRST OF ALL
THAT CAN GET OF MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA.
UNLESS OF WE WOULD LIKE TO PULL
IT OFF.
RIGHT ON THE CONSENT AGENDA CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CHOW. CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. REYES AYE.
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT THAT IS A
BE.
TWO ZERO ZERO NINE MAIENSCHEIN
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SIX CHEN.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR
OBERNOLTE AB TWENTY THREE SEVEN
THREE ACOSTA AND AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX ALSO MAIENSCHEIN.
I WILL ALSO NOTE THAT.
WE HAD TO ITEM SCHEDULED FOR
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS AT
ELEVEN WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS ONE OF
THE BILLS A. B..
THIRTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT ITEM
NUMBER TWO WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHORS THAT WE WILL NOT BE.
HEARING THAT BUT WE GOT NOTICE
THAT LATE
SO WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT.
I TRIED TO CANCEL THAT SPECIAL
ORDER OF BUSINESS BUT IN
FAIRNESS TO WITNESSES WHO MIGHT
HAVE WANTED TO ATTEND.
DURING THAT PERIOD WE'RE GONNA
STILL HOLD THAT AT ELEVEN SO.
BEAR WITH US THIS MORNING.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT AND I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT MS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER IS HERE ON BEHALF OF
CRISTINA GARCIA.
AND WITH THAT LET'S GO THE
ENTIRE NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY NINE. MISTER
HARPER.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS
I'M HERE PRESENTE BE TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY NINE WHICH WOULD
ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
STAFF.
AND STUDENTS TO USE STATE FUNDS
TRAVELED COLLEGIATE CONFERENCES
COMPETITIONS I AS WELL AS
ATHLETIC COMPETITIONS THERE
CURRENTLY BANNED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHEN THE STATE FUNDED BAN ON
TRAVEL WAS ENACTED THE AUTHOR
THE BILL DID NOT INTEND CREE
PROBLEMS WITH THE SCIENTIFIC OF
AN ATHLETIC COMMUNITIES. IN MY
OF BELIEF UNFORTUNATELY THIS
TRAVEL BAN AFFECTS STAFF AND
STUDENTS AT STUDENTS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE. SUCH AS UCLA SAN JOSE
STATE AND CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO.
STUDENTS WHO STRUGGLE WITH FOOD
AND SECURITY IN EXPENSIVE RENTS
ARE NOW PROHIBITED FROM
RECEIVING STATE FUNDS. TO ATTEND
EDUCATIONAL RESEARCH CONFERENCES
UC DAVIS SENIOR MARK RIVERA
WHICH ONE OF THE MANY COLLEGE
STUDENTS IMPACTED BY THE TRAVEL
BAN.
HERE AT LEAST SEVENTEEN OTHER
STUDENTS WERE UNABLE PRESENT
THEIR RESEARCH
AT A NATIONAL CONFERENCE ON
UNDERGRADUATE RESEARCH LAST
YEAR.
SINCE WAS HELD AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF MEMPHIS IN TENNESSEE.
STUDENTS FROM CAL POLY CHAPTER
ON THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
MINORITY ARCHITECTS
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO ATTEND THE
CONFERENCE LAST OCTOBER IN
HOUSTON TEXAS.
THEY MISTER OUT ON OPPORTUNITIES
PARTICIPATING DESIGN
COMPETITIONS AND POSSIBLY LAND
INTERNSHIPS WITH SUCCESSFUL
COMPANIES.
IN ADDITION COLLEGE ATHLETES
WERE PREVENTED FROM FACING THE
BEST COMPETITION THE NATION.
JUST LAST YEAR UC BERKELEY'S MEN
BASKETBALL TEAM WAS FORCED TO
WITHDRAW FROM SCHEDULING TWO
GAME SERIES WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF KANSAS.
CALIFORNIA'S PLAYING POLITICS.
EDUCATION CAREERS OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS
AND IT IS THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
LOSING OUT.
WHEN PRESIDENT CARTER ANNOUNCED
THE UNITED STATES WOULD BOYCOTT.
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY OLYMPIC
GAMES
IT WAS THE OLYMPIC ATHLETES WHO
MISSED OUT ON THE OPTING FOR THE
GOAL.
THE BOYCOTT DID NOTHING TO
CHANGE THE POLICIES OF SOVIET
UNION.
IN NINETEEN THIRTY SIX
THERE WAS A DISCUSSION OF WHAT
CAUGHT.
OF THE OLYMPICS IN* GERMANY
US DECIDED AGAINST.
AT THOSE GAMES JESSE OWENS.
ONE FOUR GOLD MEDALS
AND DEMONSTRATED THAT
ENGAGEMENT.
NOT ISOLATION.
THE BEST WAY TO CHANGE MINE.
LIKE THOSE OLYMPIC ATHLETES.
THESE COLLEGE STUDENTS
MAY HAVE ONE CHANCE TO LEARN AND
COMPETE AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
WE SHOULD NOT TAKE THAT
OPPORTUNITY FROM THE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU.
YOUR WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
NO IS IS WHAT WOULD ANYONE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN MICHAEL
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA. AND WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA BRINGS THE
VOICES OF LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
TRANSGENDER AND QUEER LGBTQ
PEOPLE AND ALLIES TO
INSTITUTIONS OF POWER IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES STRIVING TO CREATE
A WORLD THAT IS HEALTHY JUST AND
FULLY EQUAL FOR ALL LGBTQ
PEOPLE.
WE ADVANCE CIVIL RIGHTS AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE BY INSPIRING
ADVOCATING AND MOBILIZING
THROUGH AN INCLUSIVE MOVEMENT
THAT WORKS TIRELESSLY ON BEHALF
OF THOSE WE SERVE.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN PROHIBITS STATE AGENCIES
AND THE LEGISLATURE FROM
APPROVING STATE FUNDED OR
SPONSOR TRAVEL TO A STATE THAT
AFTER JUNE TWENTY SIX TWENTY
FIFTEEN. HAS ENACTED A LOT THAT
VOIGTS OR REPEALS EXISTING STATE
LAW OR LOCAL PROTECTIONS AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY GENDER EXPRESSION OR
HAS ENACTED A LAW THAT
AUTHORIZES A REQUIRES
DISCRIMINATION. AGAINST SAME SEX
COUPLES OR THEIR FAMILIES ON THE
SPACEY'S.
EXEMPTED FROM THE LAW IS TRAVEL
THAT IS NECESSARY TO ENFORCE
STATE LAW REQUIRED BY EXISTING
CONTRACTS OR THAT'S NECESSARY TO
PRINT PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
WELFARE OR SAFETY. AYE AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY NINE WOULD
UNDERMINE AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN BY ADDING ADDITIONAL
UNNECESSARY EXCEPTIONS FOR
CERTAIN KINDS OF STATE FUNDED
TRAVEL. THE EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE
BUILT INTO AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN ARE BASED ON THE CRITERIA
THAT THE STATE LEVEL DECISION
MAKERS ALREADY USE TO DETERMINE
TO DETERMINE WHETHER STATE
FUNDED TRAVEL IS NECESSARY. AND
THAT WHETHER IT SERVES THE
INTERESTS OF THE STATE.
THE ADDITIONAL EXCEPTIONS THAT
THIS BILL WOULD ADD ARE NOT
NECESSARY IN PART BECAUSE STATE
FUNDS ARE RARELY USED TO SUPPORT
STATE TRAVEL FOR. YOU KNOW I'VE
TO SUPPORT TRAVEL FOR STATE
UNIVERSITY ATHLETICS AND
ACADEMIC COMPETITIONS FUNDS FOR
THIS TRAVEL TYPICALLYCOME FROM
OTHER REVENUE SOURCES AND
NOTWITHSTANDING THE EXAMPLES
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
CITED AND WE'VE ACTUALLY HEARD
OF A NUMBER OF SITUATIONS WHERE
PEOPLE. HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TRAVEL
USING OTHER FUNDING SOURCES THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT USING STATE
FUNDS FOR THIS TRAVEL.
I'M MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
ADDITIONAL EXEMPTIONS EVEN IF
THEY WOULD RARELY BE USED CHIP
AWAY AT THE IMPORTANT STATEMENT
THAT AB EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN
MAKES. BY ALLOWING CALIFORNIA
TAX DOLLARS TO BENEFIT STATES
THAT ENGAGE IN BLATANT
DISCRIMINATION UNDER MORE AND
MORE SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT'S REALLY OUR CONCERN HERE
IS THAT THIS. UNDERMINES THE
ULTIMATE GOAL OF AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN AND THE STATEMENT
THAT IT MAKES DONT THE
EXEMPTIONS THAT WERE ABOUT
BUILDING INITIALLY WE BELIEVE
COVER SITUATIONS THAT WILL ARISE
WHERE STATE FUNDING DOES NEED TO
BE USED FOR TRAVEL TO THE
STATES.
AND THAT THERE SHOULD BE OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
TRAVEL THAT DOESN'T USE
CALIFORNIA STATE DOLLARS TO
BENEFIT STATES THAT COULD
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
CALIFORNIANS WHEN THEY ARE THERE
IN THAT STATE. AYE AND GENERALLY
ARE BEING USED TO FRANKLY
SUPPORT THE DISCRIMINATION AT
THE STATE'S ENGAGING AND SO WE
ARE SURE OPPOSITION TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
IT'S A NOT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
WAS HARPER AM RECOMMENDING A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL I DO FIND IT
TO BE. UNNECESSARY.
INFRINGEMENT ON THE STATE LAW
THAT WAS WE JUST RECENTLY
PASSED.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTION.
THE TRIP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ALSO BE
JOINING.
THE CHAIR IN OPPOSING THIS BILL
I.
DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY.
CERTAINLY WITH THE CONTINUE
DISCRIMINATION AND WOULD ALSO
JUST POINT OUT THAT.
.
EXPERIENCE THAT WE SAW IN NORTH
CAROLINA AFTER IT. PASSED.
IT VERY.
DISCRIMINATORY BILL AGAINST.
LGBT RESIDENTS IN THAT STATE.
WHEN THE NCAA DECIDED TO
BOYCOTT THE STATE IT HAD A VERY
REAL IMPACT AND IN MOVING OF
THAT LAW INTO A BETTER DIRECTION
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE SEEN.
WHAT THE POSITIVE IMPACT OF THE
BILL THAT WE HAD PASSED
PREVIOUSLY I AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT?
?
TO USE THE WORDS OF THE AUTHOR
TO PROMOTE INCLUSION AND.
AND INCLUSIVITY AND TOLERANCE.
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY TO TO
USE WHAT PURCHASING POWER THAT
WE MIGHT HAVE.
TO TO HAVE THAT IMPACTS WITH
THAT I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY.
YOU EITHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM ME.
ALRIGHT CIGNA MISTER HARPER YOU
MAKE CLOTHES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'VE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
I I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT OINT
OUT THAT THE STATES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY LISTED. BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT FIT INTO
THIS INCLUDE ALABAMA KANSAS
KENTUCKY MISSISSIPPI.
STILL NORTH CAROLINA.
I EVEN THOUGH THAT LAW HAS
CHANGED IT'S POINTED OUT OF BY
THE MEMBER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
SOUTH DAKOTA AYE TENNESSEE. AND
TEXAS.
YOU WERE TAKE CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITIES WERE TREATING.
FROM COMPETITION WITH THE BEST
FROM COMPETITION BOUGHT FROM
CONFERENCES WITH THE BEST.
PEOPLE ENGAGE AND OFTEN GO TO
OUR UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND
CAL STATE.
TO BE WHAT THE BEST AND
ATTEMPTED AGAINST THE BEST
BUT INSTEAD.
CURRENT LAW. IS A RETREAT FROM.
AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO IMPACT
OUR PROGRAMS BOTH ATHLETICALLY
AS WELL AS ACADEMICALLY.
AND WE'VE SEEN THAT IMPACT
HAPPEN.
NOT EVERYONE CAN BUY INDULGENCES
IF YOU WILL.
AND FIND PRIVATE FUNDING.
FURTHER DIVISION TO DIVISION
THREE. UP OR ACADEMIC
COMPETITIONS WELL WEALTHY
PROGRAMS SUCH AS DIVISION ONE
ATHLETICS AT POPULAR PAKA COMBA
TWELVE COMPETITION SCHOOLS MAY
BE ABLE TO.
BY THOSE INDULGENCES
TO BE ABLE TO PAY THEIR WAY
THROUGH.
JUST AS IN THE LAST BILL.
THE ARGUMENT WAS.
SHOULD WE HAVE.
.
COURT SIR. INITIATE SHOULD THE
PETS BE PAWNS.
IN.
.
IT IN IN DISPUTES BETWEEN.
HOT FORMER MARITAL PARTNERS.
WE HAVE A SITUATION HERE'S
SHOULD OUR STUDENTS.
BE PAWNS IN POLITICAL DISPUTES
BOB BETWEEN DIFFERENT STATES
WITHIN THE UNION.
I AGREE.
CALIFORNIA'S MESSAGE CAN BE SPOT
SPREAD BUT I SAW EVERY MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE.
APPLY.
WHEN ABOUT THE SAME TIME THAT
THIS BILL WAS PASSED.
WHEN THE NATIONAL GAY MEN'S
CHORUS CAME AND PERFORM.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
AND THEY.
SAID THAT THE NEXT THING THAT
THEY'RE GONNA DO IS TRAVEL TO
NORTH CAROLINA.
NEVER ONE HERE APPLAUDED THAT.
INSTEAD OF CALLING FOR A
BOYCOTT.
SO WITH THAT I CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK UP YOUR VOTE
FOR THIS BILL. AYE AND ALLOW US.
TO ALL NOT ALLOW US TO SEE THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AND THE CAL STATE STUDENTS.
TO BE ABLE COMPETE WITH THE BEST
AMONG THE BEST AND NOT RETREAT.
AND HOW THAT COMPETE ARE I
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR ACADEMICS
AND ATHLETIC EXPERIENCE.
AND AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER HARPER.
THEIR MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MOTION IS TO PASS ON TO
APPROPRIATIONS POLL WELL PLEASE
STONE NO STONE NO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHU. CHU KNOW.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN NO KALRA. KALRA NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
RAY OF SNOW.
SO THERE IS TWO AYES IN FIVE
KNOWS WE WILL PUT THAT BELONG
CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND IF IT DOES NOT PASS
I WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR RECONSIDERATION AND EVENTS
THANK YOU WITHOUT A DEDUCTION.
THAT WILL BE GRANTED.
TO GLORIA BRINGS US TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY FIVE FIRST OFF I WANT
TO START BY ACCEPTING. THE
AMENDMENT ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS WITH APPRECIATION AND
THANKS TO A YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THEIR WORK
TO HELP CLARIFY THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ONE LET MAKE
SURE YOU KNOW THAT MORE THAN
FOUR MILLION TRAFFIC INFRACTIONS
ARE ISSUED IN CALIFORNIA EVERY
SINGLE YEAR MAKING UP
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE CRIMINAL FILINGS
IN OUR STATE. I WOULD CONSIDER
THE CONSEQUENCES OF FAILING TO
APPEAR IN COURT NOT TO MENTION
FAILURE TO PAY ADDITIONAL FINES
OVER A MINOR TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS.
SUCH AS DRIVING WITHOUT A
WORKING TAIL LIGHT FOR RUNNING A
STOP SIGN I BELIEVE THAT IT'S
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO LOOK AT
NEW WAYS OF ADJUDICATING. MINOR
TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REMAINS APPRISED OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCILS EFFORTS TO DEVELOP A
CIVIL MODEL UP WITH ADJUDICATION
OF THESE KINDS OF VIOLATIONS.
WITH PUBLIC HEARINGS AND REGULAR
PROGRESS REPORTS ULTIMATELY
RESULTING IN A PROPOSAL AYE IF
ADVISABLE.
I WITH ME THIS MORNING IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME IS CHAIRMAN OF
IS OUT AND IT WOULDN'T BE BEEN
BOND.
PERFECT ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA I
AND SHE COULDN'T ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT MAY BE
A THE MAY HAVE. YOU ABSOLUTELY.
IT WOULD GET FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE. WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
AND ELEVEN BOMB FOR JUDICIAL
COUNCIL A TOOK ME TO FIRST GRADE
TO PRONOUNCE IT PROPERLY SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA'S PLEASE TO SPONSOR
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE WE
UNDERSTAND AND AGREE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT HAS BEEN
AND SHALL CONTINUE TO BE A
DELIBERATE OPEN AND ROBUST
PROCESS FOR THIS EFFORT.
A AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS DOZENS OF STAKEHOLDERS
PRESENTED TESTIMONY AT TWO
HEARINGS OF THE FUTURES
COMMISSION. IN ADDITION TO
OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDED WHEN THE
FUTURES COMMISSION REPORT WAS
PRESENTED TO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL LAST YEAR.
WE'RE PLANNING NOW FOR A PUBLIC
SESSION IN. A CONSISTENT WITH
THE TERMS OF THE BILL ON APRIL
THIRTIETH.
SO WE WILL KEEP THIS BODY AND
THE LEGISLATURE AS A WOLE
APPRISED OF THAT PROCESS.
A WERE MINDFUL THAT EVEN WITH AS
COMPREHENSIVE AS JUDICIAL
COUNCIL POCESS HE'S OUR FOR
EVALUATING POSSIBLE LEGISLATION.
WE ALWAYS STRIVE TO ENSURE THAT
VOICES ARE HEARD ALTERNATIVES
AND OPTIONS ARE FULLY
CONSIDERED.
I AM ONE ARRIVE AT THE BEST
POSSIBLE PRODUCT AND THAT IS IN
FACT THE WORK THAT ALL JUDICIAL
OFFICER STRIVE TO ACHIEVE. AND
THE WORK OF THE FUTURES TRAFFIC
WORKING GROUP IS NO DIFFERENT.
AND THAT'S AMONG THE MANY
REASONS THAT WE.
SPONSORED THE BILL AND AND WE
ARE MUCH A GRATEFUL FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA'S
LEADERSHIP.
WE'VE SUBMITTED A ROBUST LIST
OF STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE TO DATE
OF PARTICIPATED IN SOME
ITERATION OF THE PROCESS.
ALL OF THOSE AN AND THAT LIST IS
AT IN EXCESS OF FIFTY DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS WILL BE
INVITED TO PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC
LISTENING SESSIONS GOING
FORWARD.
AGAIN THAT FIRST ONE BEING APRIL
THIRTIETH OF THIS MONTH.
AND WE WILL CERTAINLY A
CONTINUE TO REPORT AND KEEP OF
THE LEGISLATURE APPRISED OF OUR
WORK.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WITHOUT FLETCHER I HAD I JUST
I'M AND MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER
THIS.
WHY IS A COULD JUDICIAL COUNCIL
DO THIS WITHOUT THIS LEGISLATION
ACQUIRES THE BILL NECESSARY?
?
THE YES THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
COULD HAVE THE FUTURE TRAFFIC
WORKING GROUP CONTINUE ITS
PROCESS WITH OUT LEGISLATION
REQUIRING REPORTING BACK.
THERE HAVE BEEN TIMES IN THE
PAST WHERE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
BEEN CONCERNED THAT HASN'T BEEN
PROPERLY ENGAGED WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WHAT'S SOMETHING AS
SENSITIVE AND SWEEPING AS THE.
POTENTIAL TRANSITION FROM
CRIMINAL TO CIVIL ADJUDICATION
OF TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS THAT AS
MANY INTERESTED ENTITIES ARE
ENGAGED AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE
OBVIOUSLY THE LEGISLATURE.
OKAY I JUST I I THINK I'M
THINKING PROSPECTIVELY TOWARDS
NEXT COMMITTEE MORE AND KIND OF
MAYBE WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT.
THAT THE COST OF.
OF A BILL LIKE THIS THAT MAYBE
AT BECOMES A STATE MANDATE
RATHER THEM SO THE BILL ITSELF
AS WRITTEN I DON'T BELIEVE IT
THE THERE'S NO COST TO OUR
PLANNING PROCESS.
THERE MAY BE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IF
FUTURES TRAFFIC WORKING GROUP
RECOMMENDS TO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL CHANGES TO CODE TO
STATUTE TO THE RULES OF COURT.
THAT MAY CARRY WITH THAT PRICE
TAG.
BUT WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
IS A PLANNING PROCESS TRYING TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE CHANGES MAY
BE OR COULD BE AND WHAT THEY
SHOULD LOOK LIKE. BUT WE'RE NOT
ACTUALLY PROPOSING LEGISLATION
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T INTEND TO
PROPOSE LEGISLATION.
PROBABLY BEFORE THAT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
OKAY I THINK IT'S GOOD POLICY
ADDRESS ABSOLUTE WAS THINKING
FIRE AB AND WE WOULD TO WE
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT THING THAT WE DO HAVE
A MOTION A SECOND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. TO
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WILL GET
WORKED OUT CALL THE ROLL. OUT
MISTER GLORIA MIKLOS.
SUSPECT WE ASK DR. THANK.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
I. CHOW CHOW I CHU. CHU AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
CONSULT FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
RADIUS.
REYES I.
THE BILL IS OUT.
I WILL GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN LIFT THE CALL ON AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY NINE. VOTE IS TO
YES FIVE NO.
THIS IS MISTER HARPER'S BILL
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO.
MAIENSCHEIN.
SO THAT BILL DOES IN FACT FAIL.
AND.
RECONSIDERATION HAS BEEN
NOTICED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAU MOVES
ASIDE OF NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY EIGHT.
I.
I'M YEAH I'M SORRY TO MEET THE
RUSH THAT OUT OF MY.
OKAY. THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
SO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
MANGINO THOSE AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU.
WERE STILL ON AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE.
SHOP. KNOW HOW.
CHAO NO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU
START.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
FLOOR'S YOURS
GREAT THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'LL LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE CLARIFYING AMENDMENT AS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE ON
PAGE THREE OF THE ANNOUNCES.
THE BILL AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
EIGHT WOULD PROVIDE GUIDANCE IN
THE RARE SITUATION WHEN IN WHICH
HE JUST STATION ALL CARRIER.
EXPERIENCES US SUPER FEE TATIAN
AND GIVES BIRTH TO HER OWN
BIOLOGICAL CHILD THE SAME TIME
IS GIVING BIRTH TO THE BABY. OF
AN INTENDED COUPLE.
IN LATE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
WASHINGTON POST REPORTED ABOUT A
CALIFORNIA WOMEN WHO HAD ENTERED
INTO A CONTRACT TO BE A JUST
STATION ALL. CARRIER FOR A
COUPLE AND EVENTUALLY DELIVERED
THE COUPLE'S TWIN BABIES.
ABOUT A MONTH AFTER THE BABIES
WERE BORN AND LIVING AND THEY'RE
ALL NEW HOME WITH THE INTENDED
PARENTS DO JUST CREATION OR
CARRIER RECEIVED A PICTURE. FROM
THE TWINS SO MOTHER ASKING IF
THE LEGISLATION ALL CARRIER HAD
ANY CLUE AS TO WHY THE BABIES
LOOKED NOTHING ALIKE.
DNA TEST SO TAKEN SHORTLY
THEREAFTER REVEALED THAT ONE OF
THEM.
ONE OF THE TWINS WAS ACTUALLY
THE BIOLOGICAL SON OF THE JUST
ISSUED A CARRIER.
THE CARRIER HAD EXPERIENCED A
RARE MEDICAL CONDITION CALLED
SUPER FEET HAITIAN IN WHICH SHE
CARRIED. BOTH A FETUS THAT WAS
BIOLOGICALLY CONNECTED TO HER
CONCEIVED THROUGH INTERCOURSE
AND FETUS.
ARE BIOLOGICALLY CONNECTED TO
THE INTENDED PERRANCE THAT HAD
BEEN IMPLANTED THROUGH ASSISTED
REPRODUCTION. AS IT TURNED OUT
THAT YOUR STATION A CARRIER HAD
UNINTENTIONALLY GIVEN AWAY HER A
PARENTAL RIGHTS TO BE THAT SHE
HAD NO IDEA WAS BIOLOGICALLY.
HERS
SO AFTER A LONG LEGAL BATTLE THE
I JUST PATIENT CARY WAS ABLE TO
RETAIN HER BIOLOGICAL SON.
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATION IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT A MOTHER
OUT CANNOT RELINQUISH ALL THE
RIGHTS TO A BIOLOGICAL CHILD
THAT SHE DOESN'T KNOW IS HERS.
SO WITH THAT IN MIND AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT ASSISTED REPRODUCTION
AGREEMENTS CONTAIN. A DISCLOSURE
WHICH STATES THAT ANY CHILD THAT
IS CONCEIVED BY TO JUST THEY
SHOULD ALL CARRIER THROUGH
SEXUAL INTERCOURSE IS INDEED THE
CHILD OF THE JUST ASIAN OR
CARRIER. SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAP.
ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING AND SHANNON SMITH
CROWLEY REPRESENTING THE ACADEMY
OF CALIFORNIA ADOPTION LAWYERS.
BUT UP A PARTICIPATE NEW FAMILY
FORMATION. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL.
WE HAVE A LOT OFINTENDED
PARENTS COMING FROM OUT OF STATE
AND OUT OF THE COUNTRY. BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA LAWS ON CIRCUS HERE
SO STRONG. AND THIS BILL JUST
STRENGTHENS THAT FURTHER SO WE
SUPPORT AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
IPAD.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORTS.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND IS
THERE.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SINGER BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THING NOT VERSATILE DRIVE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOREVER THANK
YOU.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED KALRA PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAU TIE
CHAO AYE CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN. KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
GEN IRIS.
REYES I.
THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT.
THEN WE'LL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWO OH FOUR FOUR WHICH
IS MY BILL THIS MAIENSCHEIN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CHAIR.
BEEN WAITING FOR THIS MOMENT.
I CHAIR IS CAN BE SOME BIG
CHANGES WHILE YOU. THAT THAT
THAT BY APPROACH.
AND I'M GOING TO REGRET THAT
THEY GO OUT ON A GAVEL AND A
GAVEL.
SO REPUBLICANS DREAM RIGHT NOW.
THANK MISTER CHAIR YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
CHAIR JUDICIARY MAIENSCHEIN.
THAT. ISSUE AB TWENTY FOUR
NEIGHBORING OR GREAT RING THAT
YOU'VE GOT ONE YES VOTE RIGHT
NOW.
WE LIKE THAT.
IS IS AN ATTEMPT TO TRY AND
ENSURE THAT THAT CHILD SAFETY IS
AT THE FOREFRONT OF ANY.
CHILD CUSTODY DISPUTE.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CAN BE AND
AND CHILD ABUSE OF VERY VERY
SERIOUS ISSUES.
AND WENT COUPLES ARE.
CONTESTING IN DIVORCE CASES AND
LOOKING FOR TAP CUSTODY.
MAKING SURE THAT THAT CHILD IS
SAFE AND THAT WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO.
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES WITH
RESPECT TO THAT CHILD IS WHAT AB
TWENTY FORTY FOUR IS ALL ABOUT.
AS WE KNOW NOT JUST CHILD ABUSE
BUT BUT BEING WITNESS TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS ALSO CHILD
ABUSE.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL IS DOING
IS TYING TOGETHER TO EXISTING
CODE SECTIONS THAT GOVERN BOTH
CHILD CUSTODY AND VISITATION
DETERMINATIONS AND. AGAIN
SETTING IT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT STANDARD AROUND CHILD
SAFETY CLARIFYING THAT THE
PERPETUATION OF CHILD ABUSE AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND THE HOUSEHOLD WITH A CHILD
RESIDES IS DETRIMENTAL TO THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE OF
THAT CHILD. AND THAT CHILDREN
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE SAFE AND FREE
IF YOU.
THIS BILL ALSO STRENGTHENS
EXISTING PERCEPTIONS AROUND THE
IN AGAINST A CUSTODY TO A
BATTERER AND SET SOME STANDARDS.
ALL AROUND ASKING COURTS TO LOOK
AT THAT AGAIN TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM BEING PLACED
UNNECESSARILY WITH A BATTERER
AND THERE'S SOME SOME DETAILS
THAT YOU SEE YOU SEE IN THE BILL
ABOUT HOW WE GO THROUGH THAT WE
ASK THE COURTS TO GO THROUGH
THAT PROCESS.
SO IT'S A CHILD SAFETY BELT
SOMETHING THAT IS BANNED LONG
OVERDUE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIGHT
SANKEY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S NANCY LEMON I'M AN
ATTORNEY I.
HAVE BEEN ATTORNEY SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND I'VE BEEN
FOCUSING ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ISSUES BLANTYRE CAREER. I TEACH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE LAW AT
BERKELEY BOLT HALL SCHOOL OF LAW
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND
DIRECT THE PRACTICUM THERE IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
.
STARTING I ALSO WORKED ON FEE
AMENDMENTS TO FAMILY CO THIRTY
ELEVEN AND THIRTY TWENTY THAT
ARE. TALKED MORE ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND I HELPED CRAFT THE
LANGUAGE IN FAMILY COULD THIRTY
FORTY FOUR.
THE PRESUMPTION AGAINST CUSTODY
TO BATTERERS ABOUT SIX YEARS AGO
I CO FOUNDED THE FAMILY VIOLENCE
APPELLATE PROJECT. AND WE SERVE
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE WE DON'T
CHARGE THEM ANYTHING. OUR
CLIENTS ARE SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND THEIR
CHILDREN.
IN THE SIX YEARS WE HAVE NO
SCREEN OVER ONE THOUSAND.
REQUESTS FOR ASSISTANCE.
OF WE OF COURSE CAN'T TAKE THEM
ALL BUT WE HAVE REPRESENTED
PEOPLE IN FORTY TWO CASES SO
FAR.
AND TWELVE FRIEND OF THE COURT
BRIEFS AND WE'VE OUR WORK HAS
RESULTED IN THIRTY ONE PUBLISHED
DECISIONS IN SIX YEARS.
FELT REALLY INFO INFLUENCES SO
AREA OF LAW AND WHAT WE'VE
NOTICED.
WILL BE SEEN VERY CLEARLY IS
THAT THE TRIAL COURTS ARE STILL
AWARDING CUSTODY EITHER JOINT
CUSTODY OR SOLE CUSTODY TOO MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE PERPETRATORS.
OF ABUSE AND SO WE THINK THAT
THE SECTIONS NEED TO BE
CLARIFIED IN STRENGTHENED.
TOM SPECIFICALLY.
ONE OF THE MORE CONTROVERSIAL
PARTS OF THE BILL I BELIEVE IS
THAT ENTER FAMILY CUT THIRTY
FORTY FOUR THE PRESUMPTION
AGAINST CUSTODY THE BATTERS
RIGHT NOW IF YOU ARE. A DAD WHO
IS SEPARATED FROM THE MOM AND
YOU HAVE THE CHILDREN IF YOU
PART TIME. AND YOU ARE ABUSING
YOUR CURRENT GIRLFRIEND OR
SPOUSE EVEN IF YOU'RE CONVICTED
OF THAT. THAT DOES NOT RAISE THE
PRESUMPTION
AGAINST CUSTODY.
DONE AND WE THINK THAT IT NEEDS
TO BE INCLUDED.
SO IT'S NOT JUST THE OTHER
PARENT OF THE CHILD THAT WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT HAS THAT
PERSON ABUSED THEM. FOR MOMMA
THE CHILD BUT ALSO HAS THE DAD
OR. COULD BE A MOM.
ABUSE THEIR CURRENT PARTNER.
BECAUSE THE CHILDREN SHOULD NOT
BE EXPOSED TO THIS PERIOD.
ANOTHER PART SETS IN THAT
SECTION THIRTY FORTY FOUR IS TO
CLARIFY THE FIVE YEARS.
PROVISIONS SO IT WOULD SAY THAT
THE FIVE YEARS.
AND UNDER WHICH THE PRESUMPTION
APPLIES STARTS WHEN THE COURT
MAKES ITS INITIAL FINDING OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND THIS IS
VERY HELPFUL. BECAUSE IT'S SORT
OF UNCLEAR FRANKLY IN THE
CURRENT STATUTE WHEN THAT FIVE
YEARS IS SUPPOSED TO START AND
IT'S ALSO HELPFUL BECAUSE
SOMETIMES CUSTODY LITIGATION
LIKE GOLF FAMILY WHY LITIGATION.
CAN TAKE A REALLY LONG TIME WE
JUST HEARD ABOUT THAT EARLIER.
THIS MORNING AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY TRUE. AND WE THINK
THAT ONCE THAT PERSON HAS BEEN
ABUSIVE ON.
SOMETIMES THEY WILL ALSO TRY TO
DRAG OUT THE QUICK PROCEEDING
AND.
IF THEY CAN MAKE IT LONGER THAN
FIVE YEARS THEN FARE US SINCE
THEY ABUSE THEIR PARTNERS THEN
THE PRESUMPTION UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW WOULD NOT APPLY AND
WE THINK THAT IT. SHOULD APPLY
STARTING WITH THE FINDING OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND FINALLY A WE WERE ALSO.
IN FAVOR OF ADDING VISITATION.
TO THE PRESUMPTION RIGHT NOW.
THE COURTS OF CONSIDER THIS
STUFF ONLY IN TERMS OF CUSTODY.
BUT IT'S IF IT'S DANGEROUS FOR
THE CHILDREN TO BE IN THE
CUSTODY OF AN ABUSIVE PARENT.
THEN IT'S ALSO DANGEROUS FOR
THEM TO BE ALONE. WITH THAT
PARENT WHETHER WE CALL IT
CUSTODY OR VISITATION.
AND ALONG THE SAME LINES MANY
COURTS NOW ARE USING THE TERM
PARENTING TIME.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT CUSTODY
THEY'LL TALK ABOUT VISITATION
TALK ABOUT PARENTING TIME.
AND SO WE THINK THAT THIS.
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE CHILDREN
BEING WITH ABUSIVE PARENTS
SHOULD BE APPLIED IN ANY KIND OF
PARENTING TIME.
AND THAT THEIR TIME WITH THE
CHILDREN SHOULD BE SUPERVISED
UNTIL THE COURT DECIDES OKAY.
THEY HAVE.
REDEEM THEMSELVES THEY'VE BEEN
REHABILITATED THEY CAN NOW.
HAVE UNSUPERVISED VISITATION
LATER ON.
THE FINAL PART THAT WE'RE VERY
MUCH IN FAVOR OF IS MORE
TRAINING FOR JUDGES ON
SPECIFICALLY THE EFFECTS ON
CHILDREN. OF PEEING IN HOMES
WHERE THERE'S ABUSE GOING ON
IT'S VERY OF VERY BAD FOR THEIR
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT AND FOR THEIR
EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL SAFETY.
SO WE URGE HERE I FELT THANK
YOU.
KATHERINE CAMPBELL AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT CALIFORNIA
PROTECTIVE PARENTS ASSOCIATION.
OUR ASSOCIATION GOT STARTED
TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN THERE WAS
A CASE OF A CHILD WITH.
MULTIPLE.
STAND SHE ADDED REPORTS OF ABUSE
THEM WHO WAS FORCED TO LIVE WITH
HIS ABUSER. IN THIS CASE IT WAS
THE FATHER.
AND WE ARE SEEING ABUSE
DISMISSED IN THE COURTS AND WE
ARE NOW OF COURSE TWENTY YEARS
OUT THIS YEAR FROM THE CDC AND
THE KAISER PERMANENTE A STUDY.
THAT SHOWS THE EFFECTS OF THE
LONG TERM EFFECTS ON THE CHILD.
WHEN THERE IS ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES IN THEIR LIFE
AND IF YOU HAVE FOUR OR MORE OF
THESE EXPERIENCES.
YOU ARE TWICE AS LIKELY TO GET
CANCER AND HEART DISEASE.
IF YOU HAVE SIX
YOU HAVE TWENTY YEARS OFF YOUR
LIFE.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE KNOW
AND THE THINGS THAT WE CAN
CHANGE AND WHEN WE IGNORE THE
ABUSE. WE ARE SAYING THAT WE
WANT. I MEAN WE ARE AT A POINT
RIGHT NOW I JUST TURNED EIGHTEEN
BURKE HARRIS SPEAK WHO'S.
WHATEVER ACE EXPERTS I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND SHE HAS STATED THAT THIS IS
THREE TRILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
SPEND ON OUR ECONOMY IN THE U.
S. PER YEAR. ON HEALTH ISSUES
THAT CAN BE.
THAT CAN BE LESSENED
WE ARE.
WE ARE IN THE. THE WAVE OF THE
ME TOO MOVEMENT AND HOME IS THE
LAST PLACE PEOPLE LIKE TO THINK
THAT CHILDREN ARE BEING ABUSED.
AND IT'S THE FIRST PLACE.
THAT CHILDREN NEED TO BE SAFE.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
KEEP CHILDREN SAFE AND.
AND THIS IS A GREAT STEP I'M I'M
ASKING FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AS WELL
AS I'M GOING TO. LET YOU KNOW
THAT THE CENTER FOR JUDICIAL
EXCELLENT ALSO IS ASKING FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS TEST SHE'S
RUNNING LATE.
BUT THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
OUR CHILDREN MATTER.
AND WE KNOW THE EFFECTS WE KNOW
THE COST.
TOO ARE SOCIETY WE KNOW THE COST
TO THESE CHILDREN.
AND WE KNOW THE RISK FACTORS
WOULD JUST TWO FACED ACES GOES
UP.
TWO SUICIDE UNABLE TO FINISH
HIGH SCHOOL.
AND IT'S HURTING US.
AS A SOCIETY AND IT'S TIME THAT
WE LOOK AT ABUSE DIFFERENTLY AND
MORE STRONGLY.
AND WE DO ALSO RECOMMENDS THAT
THERE IS TRAINING THERE NEEDS TO
THESE JUDGES NEED TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT A CHILD DOES GO THROUGH.
WHEN THEY ARE WITH AN ABUSER.
AND IT'S IT'S VERY.
DETRIMENTAL WE'VE SEEN MANY OF
THESE CHILDREN.
AND AND WE WOULDN'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN TO ANYONE YET WHERE
ALLOWING IT RIGHT NOW. SO WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
IN THIS BILL AND TO KEEP
CHILDREN SAFE I'M MY FAVORITE
WORDING HERE IS.
IT IT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
SAFE AND FREE FROM ABUSE.
AND I THINK THAT WE CAN ALL SIT
HERE AND SAY THAT BUT WE NEED IT
IN WRITING WE. LIVE IN A SOCIETY
WHERE USES DISMISSED SO MUCH.
DOT.
WE NEED TO ACTUALLY PUT THESE
BILLS TOGETHER TO ALLOW PEOPLE
TO SAY YES I'M SUPPORTING THAT.
SO I I DO VERY MUCH ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTRIAL
RIGHT SECOND FROM IS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEN NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MICHELLE
BROWN A CERTIFIED FAMILY LAW
SPECIALIST.
I AM THE LEGISLATION DIRECTOR
FOR THE ASSOCIATION OF CERTIFIED
FAMILY LAW SPECIALIST I AM ALSO
THE PRESIDENT OF A OF CC
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS AN
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION
COMPRISED OF LAWYERS JUDICIAL
OFFICERS. AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND I AM ALSO THE
CO CHAIR OF THE GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE FOR THE NEW
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
ON BEHALF OF.
AC FLS
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENTS TO FAMILY CODE
SECTIONS THIRTY ELEVEN AND
THIRTY TWENTY. WHICH.
STATE THAT CHILDREN DO HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BE FREE FROM ABUSE AND
THEY DO SUPPORT AND CLARIFY.
THE ISSUES UNDER THIRTY ELEVEN
WHICH GARNER'S THE HEALTH SAFETY
AND WELFARE OF CHILDREN AND
PROVIDES DIRECTION TO THE COURTS
AS TO WHAT THINGS THE COURTS
NEED TO LOOK AT. NOT ONLY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUT WHAT I SEE
MOST IN MY PRACTICE IS ACTUALLY
THE ABUSE OF NARCOTICS AND
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. THIRTY
ELEVEN AND THE AMENDMENTS I'M
GREATLY ASSIST IN THAT AS DO
THIRTY TWENTY.
WE APART WE SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENT TO FAMILY CODE SECTION
THIRTY FORTY FOUR HALF
WHICH REQUIRES THE JUDICIAL
OFFICERS TO STATE IN WRITING.
THE REASONS IF A PARTY HAS
REBUTTED THE PRESUMPTION UNDER
THIRTY FORTY FOUR. AYE BECAUSE
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY TO EIGHTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE LITIGANTS
ARE SELF REPRESENTED THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT THE JUDGES
NOT ONLY ORDER BUT WHY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST STRONGLY
OPPOSE ALL OF THEIR AMENDMENTS
TO THIRTY FORTY FOUR OF THE
FORGET THAT I APOLOGIZE TO ALSO
DO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENT TO THE GOVERNMENT
CODE.
FOR MORE TRAINING FOR JUDICIAL
OFFICERS AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN FAMILY LAW WE ALWAYS SUPPORT
MORE TRAINING FOR JUDICIAL
OFFICERS AND FAMILY LAW.
WHY DO WE OPPOSE THE AMENDMENTS
TO THIRTY FORTY FOUR?
WELL DOMESTIC ABUSE IS
ABHORRENT.
CHILDREN HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO BE
PROTECTED.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS A PERSON
IN THIS WORLD WILL DISPUTE THAT.
HOWEVER FAMILY CODE SECTION
THIRTY FORTY FOUR DEALS WITH THE
PRESUMPTIONS THAT THE COURT MUST
LOOK AT. WHEN THEY HAVE MADE A
FINDING THAT A PARTY HAS
COMMITTED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE OTHER PARENT.
THE CHILD OF THE RELATIONSHIP OR
ANY OF THE CHILD SIBLINGS FORTY
FOUR ALREADY PROVIDES THE
FACTORS THAT THE COURT LOOKS AT
TO DETERMINE WHETHER. THERE HAS
BEEN A REBUTTAL OF THE.
PRESUMPTION AGAINST JOINT.
LEGAL CUSTODY OR PHYSICAL
CUSTODY.
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS ARE
CORRECT THAT IT DOES NOT
CURRENTLY DEAL WITH VISITATION.
WE HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THE
EXPANSION OF THIS THIRTY FORTY
FOUR. UNSUPERVISED VISITATION
UNLESS THE COURT FINDS THE
PARENT WITH THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FINDING HAS REBUTTED
THE PRESUMPTION. BY COMPLETING
THE REQUIREMENTS AND THIRTY
FORTY FOUR WE BELIEVE THAT
COULD.
UNEXPECTEDLY.
WHAT THEY CALL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES COULD RESULT IN A
LOSS OF CONTACT BETWEEN A PARENT
AND A CHILD AND SITUATION?
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HAS BEEN
EXPANDED THE DEFINITION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THERE ARE
CASES THAT I'M HAVE COME UP ON
APPEAL. THAT IF YOU HAVE BEEN
WRITING LOVE LETTERS TO A A
PARTNER.
AND YOUR WRITING IS HARASSING
LOVE LETTERS THAT YOU WANT THAT
PERSON BACK
THAT'S GROUNDS FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER EVEN
GET A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST YOU
FOR THAT. SO IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE LET'S SAY THE MOM
WHO'S BEEN THE PRIMARY CUSTODIAL
PARENT HER HUSBAND LEAVES HER
AND SHE'S DEVASTATED IS WRITING.
HUNDREDS OF LETTERS PLEASE COME
BACK TO ME HONEY.
HE HAS THE GROUNDS TO GET A
RESTRAINING ORDER AND THE COURT
WILL LIKELY ORDER RESTRAINING
ORDER AGAINST THIS PRIMARY
CUSTODIAL PARENT NOW THERE'S A
PRESUMPTION AGAINST HER. HAVING
NOT ONLY CUSTODY BUT ANY
VISITATION IS NOT SUPERVISED
WITH THE CHILD WHO MAY BE HER
PRIMARY ATTACHMENT FIGURE UNLESS
SHE REBUTS THESE FACTORS AND
THIRTY FORTY FOUR. WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT THE OTHER
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE A STRONG
PROBLEM WITH IS THE EXPANSION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TO QUOTE ANY
OTHER PERSON. FOR WHOM THE PARTY
HAS HAD A RELATIONSHIP AS
DEFINED IN SECTION SIXTY TWO
ELEVEN.
OUR REASONING FOR THAT IS WE
BELIEVE IT WILL OPEN UP A
PANDORA'S BOX OF LITIGATION OF A
TRIAL WITHIN A TRIAL. SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU HAD A A COUPLE
WHO HAD A CHILD.
AND THE HUSBAND HAD A ROCKY
RELATIONSHIP WITH A PRICE YOUR
PARTNER FOUR YEARS AGO IT'S
WITHIN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
AND THERE'S NEVER BEEN ANY
DOMESTIC ABUSE IN THIS
RELATIONSHIP TO THE OTHER PARENT
TO THE CHILDREN HOWEVER IN THIS
SITUATION THEN THE PARENT WHO IS
SEEKING SOLE CUSTODY AND
SUPERVISES THE TATIAN. COULD
MAKE THE MERE ALLEGATION BECAUSE
THE AMENDMENTS JUST TALK ABOUT
AN ALLEGATION THAT THE OTHER
PARENT HAD COMMITTED DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OR DOMESTIC ABUSE
AGAINST HIS A PARTNER FOR YEARS
AGO ON A PRIOR RELATIONSHIP.
THAT WOULD BRING UP THE
PRESUMPTION IN THIS CASE.
AND THE TERMINOLOGY ALSO SAYS
THAT THERE IS JUST A MERE
ALLEGATION OF DVD THE COURT MUST
DETERMINE WHETHER THE THIRTY
FORTY FOUR APPLIES BEFORE
ISSUING ANY CUTS IN YOUR
VISITATION ORDERS. THAT COULD
CAUSE YOU TO HAVE A TRIAL WITHIN
A TRIAL AS TO WHETHER ANY D. V.
OCCURRED BETWEEN THIS PARENT AND
A PRIMARY PARTNER FOR THIS
PARENT COULD HAVE ANY
UNSUPERVISED CONTACT WITH HIS OR
HER CHILDREN. THAT GREATLY
CONCERNS US
WE ARE VERY THANKFUL THAT THE
AUTHORS OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS ME
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE AUTHOR
IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS WE WOULD
LIKE TO DO THAT.
HOWEVER WE ARE REQUESTING YOUR
NO VOTE WITH REGARDS TO THOSE
SECTIONS OF FAMILY CODE SECTION
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY FORTY FOUR ON
BEHALF OFA CFL LESS AND A FCC
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE AT QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE I WE DO HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND IT'S TO PASS
THAT I'D.
MISTER AYE STONE WYCHECK CLOSE.
I WOULD HAVE LET ME ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES I THINK.
WE'RE DEALING WITH.
SOMETHING OF THE HIGHEST ORDER
IN THAT IT'S PROTECTING OUR
CHILDREN AND WHERE EVER THERE'S
BEEN A BATTERER.
WHATEVER THEIR HISTORY. THE THE
HISTORY OF THAT THE SYSTEMS THAT
ARE PUT TOGETHER TO TRY AND
OVERCOME.
AND HELP THAT BATTERER ARE
REALLY NETWORKING RECIDIVISM
RATE IN THE BATTERY INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS IS UP IN THE ORDERS OF
OF EIGHTY PERCENT. AND SO WE DID
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A GOOD
SITUATION BATTERERS TEND TO
CONTINUE TO HURT. AND IF THEY
HEARD THAT CHILD OR ARE
BATTERING.
SPOUSE OR CURRENT PARTNER EVEN
IF IT'S NOT A RELATION TO THAT
CHILD THAT HAS A VERY
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT AND CAN BE
ABUSIVE ON THAT CHILD. THIS IS
WHY WE SET THE STANDARD WE'VE
ALSO TRIED TO SET A STANDARD
HERE.
TO ENSURE THAT THE COURT IS IN
FACT
OVERSEEING BECAUSE IT'S A
NUANCED SITUATION AND IT'S NOT
ALWAYS IT'S VERY FACT SPECIFIC
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY ALWAYS
CLEAR WE WANT THE COURTS.
TO BE OVERSEEING.
THE PROCESS HERE AND MAKES OF
THESE DETERMINATIONS BEFORE
THEY'RE GOING TOWARD CUSTODY OR
VISITATION AND IT IS JUST
UNSUPERVISED VISITATION THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. IN THIS
CASE BUT THAT BIG THAT'S RIGHT
THAT I THINK WE HAVE THIS BILL
HAS COME A LONG WAY.
SINCE IT WAS ORIGINALLY PUT
TOGETHER BECAUSE OF SOME THE
OPPOSITIONS AND THE CONCERNS
SOME THE CONCERNS. ARE.
VERY REASONABLE THAT THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED AND AND WE'RE
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO TALK WE
HAVE ANOTHER STAKEHOLDER MEETING
IN MAY. SO I THINK THIS BILL IS
WORTHY OF PASSING AT THIS POINT
I THINK THE BILL STANDS.
FROM MY STANDPOINT STANDS ON ITS
OWN NOW BUT KNOWING THAT THERE
ARE SOME CONCERNS THAT WE DO NOT
WANT TO UNNECESSARILY TAKE A
CHILD AWAY FROM A PAIR BECAUSE
THAT PARENTAL EXPOSURE IS VERY
IMPORTANT. IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THAT CHILD BUT IT HAS TO BE IN
THE SITUATION THAT IS FOR THE.
BENEFIT OF THAT CHILD FOR THE
HEALTH FOR THE WELL BEING AND
AND THE FUTURE OF THAT CHILD SO
WE'RE GONNA GET YOU TO HAVE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS. AND WORK
THROUGH THIS BUT I THINK THIS
BILL.
IS WORTHY OF YOUR SUPPORT AND I
WOULD APPRECIATE AND I VOTE
THANK YOU.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
AYE ESCORT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
STONE. AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN. KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RESTS.
REYES I.
IT'S OUT
.
I WASN'T SURE I WAS GOING TO GET
THE.
GAVEL BACK FROM MR MAINTAINED
THAT WE DID SO ALL IS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HANDLING THAT HEARING OKAY WE DO
HAVE A SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS
THAT IS AT ELEVEN.
O'CLOCK MISTER GRAYSON HAS TWO
BILLS.
AND SO IF WE COULD COME BACK AT.
TEN FIFTY SO ABOUT.
THIRTY FIVE MINUTES FROM NOW.
TAKE MISTER GRAYSON SPELL AND
THEN TAKE THE SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS. SO WE'RE GONNA.
HAVE A RECESS UNTIL TEN FIFTY
THAT IS FIVE MINUTES BEFORE
ELEVEN.
THANK YOU
ANOTHER.
YEAH I.
THE NUMBER GIVEN TO CHANGE HER
MIND.
SO THE TIME BEING TEN FIFTEEN
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY IS WANTING TO
COME BACK INTO SESSION AND DO
OUR LAST.
TWO BILLS WERE MISSING THE
AUTHOR MR GRAYSON AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU GET THEM HERE THAT WOULD BE
LOVELY
OUR AUTHORS HERE SO WE WILL
RECONVENE.
MISTER GRAYSON.
WELCOME.
TO TAKE UP AB TWENTY TO FORTY.
RIGHT.
IT IS OUR ITEM NUMBER FOR THE
TWENTY TO FORTY MISTER
GRAYSON'S.
BILL
PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING AND I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT DO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO FORTY RELATING TO
TRIAL JURY SELECTION.
FOR SOMEONE LIKE TO THINK THE
COMMITTEE ON THE SPONSOR.
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR WORKING TOGETHER
ON THIS LEGISLATION HIGH I DO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
AB TWENTY TO FORTY WOULD EXEMPT
PROBATION PAROLE AND
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS.
A JURY DUTY IN CRIMINAL TRIALS
DESPITE HAVING SWORN PEACE
OFFICERS
WHO PROVIDE CRITICAL PUBLIC
SAFETY SERVICES PROBATION PAROLE
AND CORRECTION OFFICERS ARE NOT
EXEMPT FROM SERVING ON JURY
DUTY.
THESE OFFICERS DUTIES INCLUDE
BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
SUPERVISING OFFENDERS ON POST
RELEASE SUPERVISION MANDATORY
SUPERVISION PROBATION PAROLE AND
MONITORING ADULTS AND JUVENILES
SERVING TIME INSIDE A LOCAL. OR
STATE DETENTION FACILITY.
PULLING THESE PIECE OFFICERS
FROM THEIR ASSIGNMENTS CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT THEIR
RESPECTIVE AGENCIES ABILITY TO
RESPECTIVELY MANAGE AND
ADMINISTER PROGRAMS AND
SUPERVISION.
THESE PEACE OFFICES ARE OFTEN IN
POSITIONS WHERE THE DEFENDANT IN
A CRIMINAL TRIAL WHERE THEY ARE
SERVING JURY DUTY.
COULD POTENTIALLY ALSO BE UNDER
THEIR WATCH AND JURISDICTION IN
THE FUTURE.
THIS CONFLICT CAN CREATE A
PUBLIC SAFETY RISK TO THESE
PEACE OFFICERS BY REQUIRING
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION TO BE
SHARED DURING THE COURSE OF THE
JURY SELECTION AND OR TRIAL. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I DO HAVE.
SOME.
THE TESTIMONY OF SOME WITNESSES
SO I WILL GIVE MY TIME OVER TO
THEM TO SELF INTRODUCED.
THANK YOU.
FIRST WHAT GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA A PLEASED
TO BE A SPONSOR ONE THAT THINK
IT'S AMONG MEMBER I FOR CARRYING
THE SUPPORT ISSUE. ALL THE FOR
MY TIME INTRODUCE AYE CHIEF MARK
PANINI WHO IS THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER AMADOR COUNTY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AT THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TED TODAY TO TESTIFY.
AND THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON.
FOR ASKING ME TO SPEAK. ON THIS
IMPORTANT. ISSUE IN THE NEED FOR
AB TWENTY TO FORTY. AS YOU'VE
HEARD WITH THE AGREED UPON
AMENDMENTS TODAY AB TWENTY TO
FORTY WOULD CHANGE CURRENT
STATUTE TO EXEMPT PROBATION
COROLLA CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS.
FROM JURY DUTY IN CRIMINAL
MATTERS.
CURRENTLY SHARES POLICE EACH
PIECE SAM'S ESCOBAR POLICING UC
AND CSU POLICE ARE EXEMPT.
FROM CIVIL AND CRIMINAL JURY
DUTY AB TWENTY TWO FORTY WAS
SEVERAL SIMILARLY EXEMPT
PROBATION OFFICERS FROM JURY
DUTY IN CRIMINAL MATTERS.
AND BRING SOME LEVEL OF PARITY
WITH ADAM ARE PEACE OFFICERS AS
FAR AS THE EXEMPTIONS GO.
PROBATION OFFICERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR CRITICAL PUBLIC
SAFETY SERVICE INCLUDING
SUPERVISING OFFENDERS ON POST
RELEASE COMMUNITY SUPERVISION.
MANDATORY SUPERVISION AND FELONY
PROBATION.
WE SUPERVISE OVER THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND ADULT FELONS IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE ARE ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
OPERATION AND PROGRAMMING IN
JUVENILE HALLS CAMPS AND
RANCHES.
IN PROVIDING SERVICE TO YOUTH IN
THE COMMUNITY INCLUDING
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL THERAPY
WRAPAROUND SERVICES REFERRALS TO
MENTAL HEALTH. SUBSTANCE USE
A DISORDER TREATMENT VOCATIONAL
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING AMONG
OTHER THINGS.
SERVING ABOUT THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND YOUTH STATEWIDE AND YES
WE DO SUPERVISE JUVENILE PAROLE
AS WELL.
JUVENILE PAROLEES.
POINT PROBATION OFFICERS AWAY
FROM OUR PEACE OFFICER DUTIES.
A PROVIDING FOR THE SUPERVISION
PROGRAMMING AND TREATMENT OF
ADULT AND JUVENILE OFFENDERS TO
SERVE ON JURIES.
SIGNIFICANTLY SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPEDES THAT WORK.
AS AN ARM OF THE COURT PROBATION
OFFICERS PREPARE REPORTS FOR THE
COURT.
WHICH INCLUDE RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING SENTENCING
SUPERVISION ARE SUPERVISING
OFFENDERS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHICH INCLUDES ENFORCING LAWS
AND SUPER ES SUPERVISION OF AND
THEIR CONDITIONS AS FAR AS IF
THE VIOLATE THE SUPERVISION
CONDITIONS.
PROBATION OFFICERS HAVE PRE
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR
FELLOW CURRENT EXEMPT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
WE SERVE ON JOINT TASK FORCE.
AND GENERALLY SUPPORT EACH OTHER
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY COMMUNITY
STRIVING FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE ROLE PUTS OFFICERS IN A
POSITION WHERE THE DEFENDANT IS
A.
THE DEFENDANT IN A CRIMINAL
TRIAL COULD POTENTIALLY BE UNDER
THEIR JURISDICTION CREATING AN
INHERENT CONFLICT OF INTEREST
AND PUBLIC SAFETY RISK TO THE
OFFICERS.
EVEN THOUGH CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
FOR US TO REQUEST NEXT TO
REQUEST AN EXCUSE OR RESCHEDULE
THAT THE REQUEST IS NOT ALWAYS
GRANTED. AND RESCHEDULING MERELY
JUST KICKS THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD.
BASED ON WHAT I'VE LAID OUT
BEFORE.
ADDITIONALLY IT IS IMPERATIVE
OFFICERS ARE NOT PUT IN
SITUATIONS
WHERE THEY HAVE TO SHARE
PERSONAL INFORMATION AS PART OF
THE JURY SELECTION PROCESS.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN OUR ROLE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM A
SUPERVISING OFFENDERS AND THIS
RECENTLY. THAT HAS HAPPENED TO
ME M. I'M I'M THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER MY.
PRESIDING JUDGE.
WAS A. HAVE PRESIDING OVER A
CRIMINAL MATTER AND I WALK IN
THE DOOR ARABS IN OBSERVANCE OF
MY JURY DUTY RESPONSIBILITY. AND
I WAS CALLED INTO THE BOX
I WAS.
.
JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER JR.
HAD TO DIVULGE AND MY WIFE'S.
NAME
AB YOU ARE ARE AT CURRENT CITY
WE LIVE IN THE SCHOOLS IN MY AND
KIDS ATTEND. NAM AND ULTIMATELY
THIS WAS A CRIMINAL MATTER AND
THE BARTENDER TO WRAP UP THE
CENTER. DEFENDER ULTIMATELY.
WAS IF FOUND GUILTY AND WAS
PLACED ON CASELOADS THAT I'M NOT
RESPONSIBLE TO SUPERVISE.
SO WITH THAT I JUST WONDER AGAIN
REITERATE THAT.
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY.
REALLY RECOGNIZES THE ROLE THAT
THAT PROBATION OFFICERS BY
WITHIN PUBLIC SAFETY AND I WOULD
ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EQUIPMENT.
CHAIRMAN A GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
COMMITTEE ALBERTA RECORDS
ANYTHING COALITION PROVISION
ORGANIZATIONS.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT OF
THE ISSUE OF.
IT'S BEEN RAISED BY THE AUTHOR
THINKING WAS GRAYSON.
AND THE CHIEFS.
REGARDING THE POTENTIAL
CONFLICT AND AND THE DANGER THAT
THESE MEMBERS OF THE EXPRESSION
OF SUPPORT AND. ISRAEL IS A REAL
THING
YOU KNOW I REPRESENT OF THE RANK
AND FILE MEMBERS.
NUMEROUS STORIES OF MEMBERS
HAVING SERVED ON.
CRIMINAL TRIALS INCLUDING MURDER
TRIALS
WHERE THEY ARE WITH THE AGAIN
THERE.
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
WE'RE NOT SURE WHO'S IN THE
AUDIENCE THERE COULD BE OTHER.
MEMBERS THAT THE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN.
PROCESS BY THE BARRAGE OFFICER
THE PRICE DROPS OF REPORT MAY
RESULT IN THOSE PEOPLE BEING
SENT TO PRISON.
THEY CERTAINLY HAVE AN AXE TO
GRIND SO FOR US.
THE ISSUE WAS ONE OF SIX
PARAMOUNT SAFETY MAKING SURE
THAT THE POLICE OFFICERS ARE
REQUIRED TO DIVULGE INFORMATION.
OTHER VERSIONS IS BILL WERE
PASSED IN ONE OF THE ISSUES
RAISED BY OPPOSITION WAS. THAT
AS A MATTER OF COURSE BRITISH
OFFICERS ARE TYPICALLY ALMOST
ALWAYS DISMISSED FROM JURY DUTY.
THAT THAT CASE.
THE CHEAPEST
TORTURED HIS STORY BUT OUR
OPERATION OFFICERS HAVE
ROUTINELY GOT TO THE BORDER
PROCESS HAVE NOT EVEN BEEN
SEATED ON CRIMINAL TRIAL SO. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVELS
MENTAL.
IF ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
TO MAKE ROOM FOR THE OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING.
ANDY LEVON BOMB JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST OPPOSE
TWENTY TO FORTY.
EVEN IS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
THE COUNCIL HAS A LONG STANDING
POLICY OF OPPOSING CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTIONS FROM JURY SERVICE.
AND HAS CONTINUALLY FOUND THAT
STATUTORY EXEMPTIONS.
PACIFIC CATEGORIES OF PERSONS
FROM JURY DUTY REDUCES THE
NUMBER OF AVAILABLE JURORS.
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
SELECT REPRESENTATIVE JURIES AND
UNFAIRLY INCREASES THE BURDEN OF
JURY SERVICE ON OTHER SEGMENTS
OF THE POPULATION.
FURTHER THE COURTS HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION TO
ENSURE THAT JURY POOLS ARE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE COMMUNITY
AND THAT THERE ENOUGH
PROSPECTIVE JURORS. AT A
COURTHOUSE EACH DAY TO AVOID
HAVING TO DISMISS LAST DAY
CRIMINAL TRIALS FOR LACK OF
JURORS IN SMALL JURISDICTIONS
YOU CAN IMAGINE THIS IS EVEN
MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE THERE ARE
SO FEW PEOPLE.
PULL FROM UNDER CALIFORNIA RULES
OF COURT RULE TO. THERE IS A
HARDSHIP EXEMPTION WHEN THE
PROSPECTIVE JUROR SERVICES ARE.
QUOTE IMMEDIATELY NEEDED FOR THE
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY.
COURTS WAS CONSTANTLY BALANCE
THE NEED TO ENSURE ACCESS TO THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WITH THE NEED TO
RESPECT JURORS TIME. HOWEVER
WILL JURY SERVICE REQUIRES
SACRIFICE ON THE PART OF
CITIZENS.
EXEMPTING CERTAIN CLASSES OF
INDIVIDUALS BASED ON THE BURDEN
IT MIGHT POSE ON THEM.
UNFAIRLY INCREASES THE BURDEN ON
OTHERS.
THERE BEEN MANY CHANGES IN
RECENT YEARS DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY TO LESSEN THE
BURDEN OF JURY DUTY ON CITIZEN.
US CITIZENS SUCH AS ONE DAY ONE
TRIAL.
SO OF MANY PEOPLE CAN SHOW UP IN
THE MORNING AND BE DISMISSED BY
NOON.
IMPROVING THE SUMMONS PROCESS
TO ALLOW REQUESTS FOR EXCUSES TO
BE MADE.
BUT ALLOWING THE JURY POOL TO
COME INTO THE COURT AND. MAKING
SURE FOR EXAMPLE THAT SOMEBODY
GOES TO A CIVIL TRIAL A RATHER
THAN A CRIMINAL TRIAL IS EASIER
THAN KEEPING TWO SEPARATE LIVES.
WHO'S GETTING CALLED IN.
COURTS AND. CALL IN A GENERIC
POOL.
AND WILL ASSIGN JURORS OUT THE
BURDEN ON HAVING TO SEPARATE.
THOSE WHO WOULD BE QUALIFIED
FOR CIVIL TRIAL AND THOSE FOR
CRIMINAL TRIAL IS A BURDEN THAT
MANY COURTS CAN'T EASILY ABSORB.
AND DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR SO
FOR THOSE REASONS.
IT'S UNLIKELY THAT THE COUNCIL
WOULD CHANGE ITS POSITION GIVEN
THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LEXI HOWARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
REGRETFULLY ALSO OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY TO FORTY.
AS IT WAS ANNOUNCED IT IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED UP VERY
RESPECTFUL OF PROBATION AND THE
WORK THAT THEY DO WAS OUR
JUSTICE PARTNERS. AND VERY
RESPECTFUL OF THEIR WORKLOADS
AND THE NEED FOR THEM TO BE OUT.
I IN THE COMMUNITY AND DOING
THEIR GOOD WORK HOWEVER FOR THE
REASONS US STATED BY MISLEADING
BOMB ALSO OPPOSED ALSO AWARE
THAT. WHILE WE ARE CONCERNED FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY REASONS OF NOT
ONLY PROBATION OFFICERS AND
OTHERS WHEN THEY COME TO COURT.
TO A SERV POTENTIALLY FOR JURY
DUTY THAT IF THEY HAVE A REASON
THAT THEY THINK THEIR EXCUSE
NEEDS TO BE HEARD PRIVATELY IN
FRONT OF THE JUDGE. EVERY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC HAS THE RIGHT TO
ASK FOR THAT AND JUDGES.
GENERALLY GRANT IT
A I HAVE HEARD ANECDOTAL
STATEMENTS AND WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WHEN THIS BILL WAS LAST
SUGGESTED. THAT JUDGES DON'T
ALWAYS ENTERTAIN THAT BUT I'VE
ACTUALLY NEVER HEARD THAT TO BE
THE CASE. IF WE HEAR THAT WE
CONSIDER THAT TO BE ONE OF
EDUCATION AND NOT THAT NEEDS A
STATUTORY PROVISION JUDGES DO
FOR CARE VERY MUCH ABOUT THE
JURY POOL. AND WANT PEOPLE TO
FEEL SAFE COMING TO THEM AND SAY
SAYING WE NEED AN EXCUSE BUT WE
CAN'T TALK ABOUT THAT PUBLICLY.
SO RESPECTFULLY WE ARE STILL
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY TO FORTY WE
DO PLEDGED TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING MORE THAT
WE CAN DO HERE. BUT JUDGES ALSO
SERVE JURY DUTY IT IS A
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF OUR
DEMOCRACY AND WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT ASKING THE PUBLIC TO DO
THINGS THAT. OTHERS ARE WILLING
TO DO.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
AMENDMENTS MISTER GRAYSON AND
THIS ISN'T AN ISSUE THAT I HAVE.
ALWAYS BEEN VERY VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT AND FACT. A LOT OF THE
TESTIMONY AND IT WAS BUT I WAS
FINE WITH THIS MOVING FORWARD
WITH THE AMENDMENTS BUT SOME THE
TESTIMONY RAISES EXACTLY THE
ISSUES THAT I HAVE. AND.
GOES RIGHT TO MY CONCERNS JUST
BECAUSE SOMEONE ELSE HAS THE
ABILITY TO GET OUT OF JURY DUTY
DOESN'T MEAN ANOTHER GROUP
SHOULD HAVE THAT. I DON'T BUY
THAT AT ALL. AND BECAUSE YOUR
JOB IMPORTANT AND I'M NOT
MINIMIZING YOUR JOBS AT ALL I
THINK THEY'RE CREDIBLY PORT I
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH.
PROBATION SHE SAID APPROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS AS RESPONSIVE AS IT POSSIBLY
CAN BE AND ESPECIALLY TO THE
NEEDS OF THOSE. IN YOUR CARE
WHETHER IT'S JUVENILES OR
ADULTS.
TO GET OUT OF JURY DUTY FOR THAT
REASON THERE ARE. ANY NUMBER OF
CATEGORIES WHERE WE WOULD IF WE
FOLLOW THAT LOGIC WE WOULD BE
ACCEPTING PEOPLE FOR JURY DUTY
THAT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE.
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR DEMOCRACY
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM
IS THE OBLIGATION FOR ALL OF US
TO SERVE ON JURIES I'VE SERVED
I'VE I'VE SHOWED UP I THINK
KICKED OFF.
I AS A LAW STUDENT I SERVED ON A
JURY Y. I WAS LET STAY ON AS A
LAW STUDENT STILLS I SCRATCH MY
HEAD OVER BECAUSE THAT'S
PROBABLY THE WORST OR YOU COULD.
HAVE WAS ME AS A LAW STUDENT.
BUT IT'S HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS
AND IF WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
FIND EXCUSES
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET OUT OF
JURY DUTY. THEN WE MINIMIZE THE
POOLS WE WE STE
FUNDAMENTALLY TAKE.
A REAL HIT TO OUR OVERALL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND OUR
OBLIGATIONS AS CITIZENS.
THERE ARE MANY OCCUPATIONS THAT
ARE VERY IMPORTANT AND.
THAT THAT THAT BEING THE REASON.
IS REALLY BEYOND ME THE THE FACT
THAT YOU ARE POTENTIALLY
SUPERVISING SOMEBODY WHO'S THERE
THAT YOU ARE.
HAVING A RELATIONSHIP OR THAT
YOU MIGHT.
PUT YOURSELF THAT AT SOME
POTENTIAL RISK.
OKAY IN A CRIMINAL CONTEXT I SEE
THAT THE REGIONAL BILL WAS FOR
CIVIL. THAT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT
TRUE.
AND SO THAT'S WHY IT WAS
ACCEPTABLE TO.
TO TAKE TO PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AND AND REALLY ONLY TALK ABOUT.
THE CRIMINAL SIDE OF THINGS BUT
IT YOU KNOW THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. DON'T MISTAKE THIS
COMMITTEES PERSPECTIVE ON IT
THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO BE OPENING UP.
ANYBODY THE COME FORWARD AND SAY
MY JOB IS TO IMPORTANCE
TO TO. WALK AWAY FROM MY
FUNDAMENTAL OBLIGATION AS A
CITIZEN OF THIS COUNTRY AND
SERVE ON JURY ME THAT CAN'T BE
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT THAT
CAN'T BE WHAT THIS DIRECTION IS
ABOUT. SO I I JUST GOTTA PUT
THAT ON THE RECORD. THAT WAS
WHAT MOST THE TESTIMONY WAS THAT
TO ME WAS PERSONALLY VERY
FRUSTRATING SINCE I. THOUGHT WE
WERE PRETTY CLEAR AND IN WHY WE
WERE.
DO ANY AMENDMENTS THAT WE DEBT
SO ANYWAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBER.
ALRIGHT SING NONE MISTER GRAYSON
UN CLUB.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
AND.
AND THE RIGHT PERSPECTIVE AS
FAR AS MAKING SURE THAT WE DON'T
OPEN THIS UP.
FOR ANYBODY THAT JUST FEELS THEY
HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT DUTY OR
JOB OR THE CONTRIBUTING IN A
PARTICULAR WEIGHT TO SOCIETY.
BUT THEY FEEL THAT.
IT SHOULD EXEMPT THEM FROM
THEIR DUTY.
AND SO.
IN ADDRESSING.
THE REQUEST HERE AND THE
CONTENT THAT THE MEDIA THE BILL
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT PROVIDING
AND IT'S NOT AT ALL PROVIDING. A
A MEANS OF CONVENIENCE
FOR A PARTICULAR INDUSTRY OR A
PARTICULAR GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
JUST DON'T WANNA SERVANT JURY
THAT DUTY THIS IS ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
IT'S ABOUT RECOGNIZING THAT
SWORN OFFICERS
SWORN PEACE OFFICERS.
ARE EXEMPTED FOR A REASON.
AND THAT PROBATION BASED ON SOME
OF THE EFFECTS UNINTENDED AS
THEY MAY BE.
SOME OF THE AFFECTS OF PROP OF
FORTY SEVEN.
AND AB ONE OH NINE TO WHERE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF PROBATION
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN ENHANCED.
THEY HAVE ALSO BECAUSE OF THE
REALIGNMENT.
THEY HAVE ALSO NOW BEEN PUT IN
A POSITION WHERE THEY FACE EVEN
MORE DANGERS.
THAN THEY WERE BEFORE AN YOU
HEARD THE TESTIMONY OF BEING ON
THE STAND AND DELIVERING
PERSONAL INFORMATION WHICH IS
WHY WE WOULD EXEMPT. ADD ON
ANOTHER GROUP FOR THAT SAME
REASON SO I FULLY AGREE.
DATA THIS SHOULD NOT BE IN THE
OPEN DOOR FOR JUST ANY GROUP TO
BE ABLE TO COME FORWARD BUT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE PRECEDENT ALREADY FOR. AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY CAUSING THIS
PRESIDENT TO BE ABLE TO REACH
OUT AND BRING IN WITH.
WITH THE TESTIMONY THAT WE'VE
HAD AND WITH MUCH MUCH RESPECT.
THE TESTIMONY THE OPPOSITION AS
WELL AND ALSO YOUR WORKS MISTER
CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY HAS FOR
NIGHT VOTE TODAY.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU A
IS THERE A MOTION MOTION WOULD
BE TO DO PASSES AMENDED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THERE'S A MOTION IS THEIR
SECOND.
AND THE SECOND
THANK YOU COVERUPS WITH STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU.
CHIU I CURRENT GONZALEZ FLETCHER
HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN RACE.
REYES I.
THAT NEEDS TO MORE VOTE SO WE
WILL PUT IT ON CALL ONCE WE GET.
OUR FULL COMMITTEE BACK.
RIGHT ITEM NUMBER ONE AB THREE
THOUSAND AND TWO.
AND JUSTICE THAT ASIDE
TWO OF MY THREE PROBATION
SHEEP'S
SHE'S IN MY DISTRICT OPPOSE THE
BILL.
BANQUETTES.
FOR CONTACTS.
THERE'S STILL MORE WORK TO BUT
THAT'S ALRIGHT. AB THREE
THOUSAND TO MISTER GRACE.
WHAT YOU'RE WITNESSES SHOW UP?
WE'LL TAKE A SECOND TO.
SWAT PERSONNEL HERE
.
ALRIGHT WHEN YOU READY.
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
GOOD TO BE IN FRONT YOU. AGAIN
YET AGAIN.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THOUSAND TO
WHICH IS A PROACTIVE MEASURE
THAT PROVIDES HELPFUL RESOURCES
AND INFORMATION TO BUSINESS
OWNERS TO INCREASE THEIR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE AMERICAN
DISABILITIES ACT.
EIGHTY A AND RELATED LAWS AND
REGULATIONS THE GUARANTEE EQUAL
ACCESS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES
FIRST. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS LEGISLATION AND I
DO EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS PER THEIR ANALYSIS.
MEMBERS
AB THREE THOUSAND TO IS THE
RESULT OF APRS OF MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON HOW BEST TO
PROVIDE BUSINESSES WITH BETTER
INFORMATION ABOUT THE EIGHTY A.
AND A AND CONNECT THEM WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
AID WITH COMPLIANCE.
TOO OFTEN BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WITH IT
WELL. HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES AND
THEY'RE UNAWARE OF THE IN
INTRICACIES OF THESE LAWS WHEN
CONSTRUCTING OR MODIFYING THE
PUBLIC FACILITIES.
KEY IS GETTING THE INFORMATION
INTO THE HANDS OF BUSINESS
OWNERS EARLY IN THEIR PLANNING
PROCESS BEFORE THE SHOVEL HITS
THE GROUND. THAT IS WHY OF
AUTHORED THE BILL TO REQUIRE ANY
LOCAL AGENCY THE ISSUES BUILDING
PERMITS.
FOR RENOVATION OR NEW
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS TO ATTACH
AN INFORMATIONAL EIGHTY A NOTICE
DIRECTLY TO THE APPLICATION FOR
A BUILDING PERMIT.
THESE NOTICES WILL ALSO WHEN.
INCLUDE INFORMATION ON WHERE TO
FIND CERTIFIED ACCESS.
SPECIALIST
IN THEIR AREA WHO CAN INSPECT
BUILDINGS AND SITES FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH APPLICABLE STATE
AND FEDERAL. A CONSTRUCTION
RELATED ACCESSIBILITY STANDARDS
AND FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
I DO HAVE A WITNESS IN
IN THE FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
EVELYN I WILL HAVE SOME WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
DO SUPPORT THE MEASURE IT'S
IT'S.
GOOD TO SEE PROACTIVE ON
LEGISLATION THAT.
MAINTAINS THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
PEOPLE TO PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AFTER SO MANY YEARS
OF WORKING.
SO HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROTECT THOSE RIGHTS I'M AND AND
DEALING WITH REACTIVE MEASURES
RATHER THAN PROACTIVE ONCE AND
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL. WE WERE PART OF THE
STAKEHOLDER DISCUSSIONS THAT
THAT THE MEMBER HAD AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE PROACTIVE
MEASURES TO MAKE SURE OUR CIVIL
RIGHTS ARE PROTECTED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND MISS GRAYSON OUT I
DO WANT TO THANK YOU AND I.
IMMENSE RESPECT FOR YOUR
DIRECTION WITH WITH THIS BILL WE
HAD TALKED ABOUT THIS EARLIER IN
THE YEAR.
AND YOU ARE DEATHLY GOOD YOUR
WORD SAID TO HAVE A STAKEHOLDER
MEETING IN GO THROUGH THIS. TOO
OFTEN SOMEBODY GETS A BRIGHT
IDEA AND DOES NOT. ENGAGE WITH
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND WHAT WE END UP
DOING IS A ROAD IN PROTECTIONS
AND ERODING. PEOPLE'S CIVIL
RIGHTS AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND IT'S IT'S GREAT THAT. THERE
IS AN ISSUE.
UNDENIABLY AND TO.
BE PROACTIVE ABOUT IT TO COME
FORWARD WITH SOMETHING THAT
THAT'S REALLY GOING TO GIVE
PEOPLE INFORMATION THE TOOLS
THEY NEED.
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM BEFORE THEY
GET INTO THE PROBLEM
IS IS REALLY A GREAT DIRECTIONS.
WANT TO COMMIT.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR ADVICE.
THANK YOU ADDRESS.
I TO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING THIS PROACTIVE.
VIEW ON ON AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE ISSUE IS
RESOLVED OR AT LEAST ADDRESSED.
FOR THE ISSUE BECOMES AN ISSUE.
OF AND AND MAKING SURE THAT
STAKEHOLDERS THAT THE MEMBERS OF
THE.
.
DISABLED COMMUNITY ARE ALSO
INCLUDED IN THIS SIX STREAMING
IMPORTANT.
IT'S SUCH A GOOD BILL AYE WOULD
LIKE TO AT ADD ON AS A CO
AUTHOR.
BE WITH YOUR PERMISSION.
THANK YOU I WOULD BE HONORED
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OUR SINGER MR GRACIE MIKLOS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE LOOKING FOR A
MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND IT
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
AND IT'S GOING TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO OF PROBES.
CALDWELL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAU. CHIU AYE
CHIU.
CHIU AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
HOLDEN.
KALRA. KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THAT NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE SO SOON
AS WE GET THE REST OF OUR
COMMITTEE WE WILL FINISH OUR
BUSINESS SO CALL OUT TO ALL
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
IF YOU COULD SHOW UP THEN WE
COULD FINISH OUR BUSINESS WE DO
HAVE.
ONE BILL ON CALL.
OH SORRY BOTH.
BUT MR GRAYSON'S BILLS ARE ON
CALL.
SO.
LET'S SEE IF.
YEAH ON WHICH ONE.
OKAY SO DESCRIPTIONS FIRST BILL
AB TWENTY TO FORTY.
WHICH IS.
CURRENTLY ARE CALL I'M GONNA
LIFT THE CALL CALL ITS MEMBERS
CUNNINGHAM GONZALEZ FLETCHER
HOLDEN KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAJOR AND I.
THAT IS ABOUT ZERO SO WE.
ID ONE.
ONE MORE OKAY LET'S GO THROUGH.
YEAH OKAY THIS
KILEY SO WE HAVE.
LET'S LET'S GO THROUGH.
JUST SURFING IN.
SO CAN SET CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
OKAY
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS AB THREE
THOUSAND INTO MISTER GRAYSON'S
BILL THAT IS OUR COLUMN AND WITH
THE CALL. CHO THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CUNNINGHAM GONZALEZ FLETCHER
HOLDEN KALRA KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER.
THREE.
AB TWO OH FOUR FOUR WHICH IS MY
BILL.
CALYPSO NUMBERS CUNNINGHAM CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN KILEY.
KILEY NO.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY A MIL LIFT THE CALL
CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS
CUNNINGHAM GONZALEZ FLETCHER
HOLDEN KALRA KILEY.
KILEY NO.
AND THE TO REPLACE THE CALL THAT
IS STILL ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
WHICH IS AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY
FOUR MISTER QUIRK SPELL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
KILEY.
NOT VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER SIX TWENTY TWO
NINETY EIGHT MISTER CHAO'S BILL.
CALYPSO NUMBERS CUNNINGHAM CHIU.
CHIU AYE.
HOLDEN KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
WE HAVE EVERYBODY'S HERE'S ON
THAT. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE MISTER
GLORIOUS BILL HOLDEN. KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
OKAY IF FEW WOULD LIKE TO VOTE
ON.
BILLS THAT HAVE NOT IN ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY POLICE SHOW UP SO WE
CAN FINISH OUR BUSINESS
THANK YOU TO THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
HERE
OKAY ITEM NUMBER ONE. AB THREE
THOUSAND TWO PERSON.
CUNNINGHAM GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
OKAY I'VE NEVER FOR MISTER
PRESENTS OTHER BILL ITS AUNT
COLUMN IN A LIFT THE CALL AB TWO
TWO FOUR ZERO. CUNNINGHAM
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
THAT BILL ALRIGHT ALRIGHT THAT
BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU
.
THIS ITEM IS THE GREAT.
YEAH. THAT WAS.
OKAY ITEM ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
THREE THOUSAND INTO. GRAYSON
CAUGHT UP TO MEMBERS HOLDEN
KALRA AYE.
SORRY COLORI.
THAT WAS.
THE SOLDIERS HERE LET'S GO
THROUGH.
OKAY MISTER HOLDEN ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB THREE THOUSAND INTO
MISTER GRAYSON SPELL CUNNINGHAM.
HOLDEN. AYE HOLDEN AYE.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWO ZERO
FOUR FOUR WHICH IS MY BILL
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN I'M NOT SURE.
I HOLDEN AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FOR AB TWENTY TO
FORTY MISTER GRAYSON SPELL
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN.
I KNOW WHAT IT IS THIS THE.
NIKOLIC KEYS FIRST.
BILL.
I'M NOT SURE.
THE PRETTY WELL IT'S WELL DONE
SO I'LL OPEN A GIVEN I'VE.
HOLDEN I.
WE'VE GOT AMONG.
WE NEED.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY EIGHT MISTER CHAO'S BILL
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN AYE AYE HOLDEN
AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A. B. TWENTY
SIX FIFTY FIVE MISTER GLORIA.
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS FOR TODAY THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
WE ARE ADJOURNED